minutes late please forgive the
tardiness
ela's going to the bathroom it's 201
i'm about to start without you i am not
used to this new ethan
punk duality i welcome it
punctuality defines me i will this is it
epic
anyway happy friday everybody
welcome welcome to h3 after dog hey
everybody
53 degrees
nice sunny disposition outside you're
gonna love this
uh the day it is
danny favorite march 4th
coming at you springs right around the
corner
today's episode is sponsored by mint
mobile and the boys diabolical
the boys is making a cartoon did you
know that no
i'm down i love everything the boys i
love the boys
um
everybody good everybody's having a good
time everyone's feeling good it's friday
baby
also we're going to see batman tonight
which i'm excited about
uh
there's a lot of hype in the office here
too zach says that he
he might become riddler brain i might
become ruler right now he's gonna like
have you seen the new batman no but if i
like it then i'll become riddler brain
and workout brain well i'll tell you
what i think after tonight if you read
their breath if their brain is a good
look or not yeah i love paul dana and i
i hope he knocks the character out of
the park so um
yeah
you know we haven't been to a movie
theater in like over two years since
before
we're just gonna be so nice i'm gonna
get so much candy and popcorn i mean
i'll tell you i'm gonna get like the
nachos with the tray it's like super
ghetto i'm gonna get even that
who gets nachos at the theater i've
always wondered that's so has any one of
you ever got nachos at the theater
baby's grinning like an ass really
that like a stable i mean i don't know
because i don't have a lot of like
options we could eat because uh a lot of
like pork hot dogs and stuff so it's
like pretzels or nachos so
[ __ ] that's real interesting yeah so
it's for the halal yeah um
you know i just looked at uab and you
look buff oh [ __ ] oh yeah [ __ ] you're
getting swole i'm trying to stay married
here really
i just had to say something
well you saw his thirst trap don't act
like no i did i know i didn't talk about
you
lina keeps telling me that but i don't
see it but i appreciate it thank you i
just i noticed a difference
she said my head matches my body now so
because he said he said now that he his
the size of his head match his body you
said
well yeah his body was a little bit but
she's saying i was he was skinny before
yeah his head is massive yeah
[Laughter]
maybe well that's nice to hear from your
wife isn't it
yeah
no i'm proud of you i mean dude you put
in the work
thank you you put in the work put in the
hours and take what's ours
he's gonna devour yeah
i hope you win man i think maybe you
were saying the announcement is like
on the horizon we're gonna yeah it's
coming up hopefully not next after dark
but the one after we could announce it
then hopefully so
exciting did an idubbbz opponent get
leaked
um
i mean there was some people talking
about it but every leak that i've seen
wasn't true so okay we'll see
gonna wipe the floor with that nerd no
way he's training as hard as you right
i mean possibly he's he's uh what are
you gonna kill him he's a gym dude
are you gonna try to kill him i'm not
gonna try to kill him how many people
have died in the ring i mean at least
one oh yeah definitely let's make it two
apollo cree
rip to the goat yeah i got money on a b
so me too
right we all better nab we're all
supporting here
thank you guys except dan who's the
hater of the punch
same thing i'm ethan the lover we
actually have another fighter who's
going to be in the fight who just joined
as a member
nathan uh barnett
i hope that's how you pronounce it but
he's in the but he just joined yeah oh
[ __ ] shout out yeah that's the dancing
dude right mm-hmm
he dude you know what he makes himself
look goofy goofy but that dude is jacked
yeah he is he's like crazy athletic
he said ab will win oh thank you there
you go who's nathan fighting or you
can't say uh they actually announced it
on his twitter today he's gonna be
fighting matt watson
uh by the way my preview monitor is off
huh okay so so matt watson i'm gonna be
honest with you right now nathan let's
see
oh they did like the nerd match up is
that what this is who's matt watson he's
from supermega
and so let's let's check his stats
height
this guy is six two oh buddy
oh
and then what what's the dancing guy's
name
uh nathan barnett i hope i'm pronouncing
it i'm sorry dude if i'm pronouncing it
wrong barnett
wait b-a-r-n
dude he's so jacked you guys look at
this
like he's like ah ha ha goofy dancer
look at this oh
damn talk about thirst trap
dude that guy's yeah
that would kill it on the um
the ninja warriors oh
you know it's like a guy that looks
totally normal
first look and then they're like
actually
the greatest ninja
nathan i always wonder can you tell me
you used to always do these skittle ads
and i wasn't sure if you were being paid
for those or if you were just wanting to
do skittle ads can you respond
i've always wondered that what's the
deal with those skittle videos used to
make
um
wait i gotta look at his height i'm
sorry this is not the most interesting
content i admit i sent a tweet of them
next to each other
so wait
nathan is six foot okay yeah the height
that's a pretty rough height advantage
oh they look the same size well he's
leaning down
okay let's see i'm interested in all
these fights
he's leaning that he's definitely taller
he looks younger too eh
just the right height
he said in the chat i don't work out
just lots of dancing
yeah no i got dancing more i mean i
believe that yeah
but he's he's not like a dancer like you
think he's like an insane dancer um i
believe it that actually let me watch
some of his videos they're pretty cool
it's like one punch man he never
yeah never exercise well hold on
a great one punch man he does 100
push-ups a day in response to your uh
question he said he did those as a joke
but then they hired him as a
spokesperson oh really yeah oh that's
awesome so it worked that worked
out you guys want to see some i actually
really used to
i love these guys dance videos
wait we got a 420 blaze it donation
what's what is that about
420. we got a massive donation here from
whoa holy [ __ ] i thought this was too
much that much uh introduced
hello h3 crew huge fan fellow memester
here was hoping you would be generous
enough to read a short letter i wrote
you i'm on discord no shenanigans
well
i mean listen
100 420 i'll read whatever you send
okay i mean
i don't know is it a dissertation i mean
i do have a schedule here
well i'm not on the show this is early
but i'll read it oh i'll read it that's
right oh i thought you wanted me to i'll
[ __ ] read it yeah
nathan said he has a one punch man
tattoo actually oh he is one punch was
that a one punch man reference i'm
trying to find a good dancer
um
[Music]
he did this one where he went to like a
fake audition that's what i'm trying to
find
um
here
so anyway
this is the worst the [ __ ] of the month
here it is here it is
yeah
okay
is like old school youtube man
what is this from 2012 bro 10 years ago
[Music]
oh just mute it don't [ __ ] around yeah
yeah he goes there acting like some kind
of creepy weirdo and then he's like the
best dancer
yeah
i like it that's pretty ahead of its
time
no it was like super viral
also he's got this crazy dancing
technique too he's actually just really
good at it
oh it's awesome
yeah this was
this was a super
awesome video
[Laughter]
dude the hair really sells today that's
commitment i love the commitment the
whole outfit is very like
that vibes
on point
by the way sexual dance
i feel like he's the best dancer there
for sure and they cut his ass just
because he's probably a weirdo
they know what to make of it
it's a real audition to be a backup
dancer for some musical artist i don't
remember who
that's awesome
well there you have it yeah i haven't
met uh look at this hello
did you say i'm sorry i haven't met
nathan yeah i met matt once he was
really nice
and he's really tall
but uh yeah i'm curious to see how it's
gonna go
ah nathan i don't know man
that guy's a bit younger than you and
taller i think you might get your ass
beat
as much as i
am team nathan
but i'll be watching all right enough of
that we got a whole show to do yeah
anyways nachos are good
okay i'll get this get some mattresses
man i don't give a [ __ ] it's batman
night
so oh okay before we get started oh my
god you guys
this isn't real is it
keemstar welcome
yo welcome keemstar we knew you were a
fan
that's a joke
welcome uh he's been a uh
a member for 18 months so we welcome you
and we appreciate your
being a member
um before we get started real quick
i'm calling to all viewers
we need a designer we need designers for
teddy fresh
are you a designer
now i have to please please only
seriously please send love peace and
love
about the we need a designer bad if
you're not
an experienced designer your email will
be thrown away yes peace and love
if you do not attach a resume with
relevant experience it is going straight
to the bin i'm warning you with peace
and love
i have too much to do thank you
they've been a huge fan and they've been
watching
i'm [ __ ] i can't read it there's too
much i don't care what's going on in
your life
i want i want emails with resumes with
relevant work experience yes with peace
and love peace and love
too much to do thank you thank you thank
you but if you are and no objects to be
said and you're professional and you're
um you got experience and you can show
us then you got a real chance because
we're looking
and we have been looking for a while
honestly it's not easy it's so hard to
find good designers we're desperate now
and i'll tell you what
not only that you don't even have to
live in l.a you can live anywhere in the
world at this point we're hot we're
looking at people in england for
christ's sake and like doing visas and
stuff like we're desperate do you
understand
so anyone anywhere
with relevant work experience thank you
thank you
the best we pay better than anyone in
the business
we got great benefits
this is a good job it's a creative job
too you can flex your creativity
so designers all around the world we are
calling on you
to email you
i see people actually asking uh are you
talking fashion designers or graphic
designers uh we're talking fashion
designers but graphic designers are also
um
it's also open oh same thing though
destroyed the email no same thing you
have to be like professional with
experience show a resume we need graphic
designers yeah okay always
all right
what is that because it's just going to
increase the
same thing increase the net no it was
already going to be
there's a big i'm the one that's got to
deal with this
nobody else knows
what to do welcome to my world every
time you shout out my youtube yeah well
i'm making a new email it's jobs
teddyfresh.com there you go jobs
but i have a technique because i back
back in the day of the early days teddy
fresh i used to go on like uh
monster.com
and i would so because you know what do
you do i would sort through hundreds of
emails yeah and i've have a way of of
sifting for the gold so this is a
warning i'm not even going to read it
you understand
don't even bother don't bother
don't send me fanfic
no need for a cover letter no need for
any real
background story i don't read i mean
sometimes i recover no but in this case
because it's going to be 100
i'll get to the cover letter on the next
round yeah no but no a cover letter is
good i want to know a little bit about
that okay i see the resurrection hilo oh
i check the resume i go straight to work
experience
and then i say okay good like this past
the sniff test and then i go to the
to the cover letter also let me just say
i've had people apply for design jobs
without a portfolio that's just nonsense
so don't bother i have to see your work
i have to see something visual a serious
uh with peace and love we need a serious
resume and portfolios only thank you
thank you and it was used in a book huh
what about graphic designers especially
you want me to expand on that yeah it's
the same thing and they have do do you
need them to have relevant work with
like a big streetwear company
streetwear is preferable um but any any
like fashion
experience
okay so yeah once again jobs at
teddyfresh.com these are this is a very
serious offer
uh best pay
great benefits
it's all happening
at jobs at teddyfest.com thank you thank
you
all right
golly it's taking us a while to get
through this top of the show stuff
what about introducing our friends yeah
i'll get to that sean my friend sean is
here
some of you long time
happy to be here
some of you long time viewers may
recognize sean
he was in our old old videos when we
were israel
sean is one of my oldest friends we grew
up together went to elementary school
together middle school together
high school together
college together
oh wow we went to univer uh santa cruz
together and then israel we lived in
israel together
yeah and what a long way you've come man
really
was just asking in this right now i'm
thinking back to israel when we were
fishing through the garbage for costumes
[Laughter]
it's really something
well our costume
our costume budget hasn't changed that
much yeah but still making sure that
cardboard yeah
wait till you see uh
but anyway sean sitting in with us he's
staying with us so welcome sean welcome
sean
good to be here do you want to tell an
embarrassing story about me you're for
the one that's known me the longest
give me a few minutes yeah don't put it
into my spot take your time but also
take it easy on me okay
so
um golly uh golly that reminds me of our
very first twitch stream since sean used
to sometimes be a part of it or just sit
in the back sit in the background
all right so guys let's get on to the
good stuff shall we we shall joy behar
from the view
eats [ __ ]
yeah i love watching these women from
the view just [ __ ] up anything they get
advised they trip and fall whippy got
cancelled for saying that jews aren't a
race or something do we ever talk about
the whooping controversy i don't think
we touched on it on the show no she did
a whoopsie dupsy whoopsie-doopsy
whoopsie whoopsie goldberg more like
yeah she got suspended is she back on i
guess yeah it was like two weeks
suspension that she had
i love that like a sports team like she
got a
she got to sit on the bench for two
weeks
it was kind of a weird take i have to
agree but i mean i i don't know i don't
know about like putting her in this on
the ice
but anyway here's joy behard eating [ __ ]
i'm desperate without windy man
i'm watching old ladies fall down
this is what we get
watch closely oh you'll miss it because
they're cut into the audience
[Music]
boom
she tumbled
she's straight that was a trumpet here
we're gonna have to go frame by frame is
her chair missing what happened
was she gonna she missed her chair when
she was gonna say yeah okay so this is
gonna be a frame by frame because it's
not easy to see but she really she
tumbled man
doing a dodge roll
okay now here we're seeing uh
a dodge roll for sure she's 79 that
could be fatal oh my god at that age
why'd you have to point that out dude
come on she gets back up and does the
show she's fine
she's 79 she looked pretty good for that
eh
but here she is she's kind of it's all
happening
and she's on her ass
now she's tumbling
the legs in the air oh my god
that sound
oh my god i'm surprised she shot back up
from that at 79.
oh sh
wait did she go down a stage too
where did she go oh okay no
there she goes
i love the shot it's like all fancy and
panning through the ball
so guys yes times are times are
desperate we got joy baehart
taking a dip
she has internal bleeding at that age
she's trooping it up but she'll be dead
by tomorrow
there you have it guys hey
what a what is what uh
wow what a way to start the show
i mean
that's like normally embarrassing but
then to have that happen to you on
television yeah wait
[Laughter]
she just stumbled like a like a
blueberry baruch assault
just rolling
um you know what we've been talking a
lot about
wait we have more falls you guys oh my
goodness what a bountiful day yeah we
figured if we're doing this we gotta we
gotta go all out so this is a clippers
reporter falls after the game
came out executed
what the hell happened there did he trip
her or something no what how did she eat
[ __ ] and why why'd they angle from above
yeah
how do you even get that angle it's like
they knew it was gonna happen
wait something swept their feet it looks
like you swept the leg i don't know
no i
i think her shoe just slipped apparently
what happened is they uh put some water
on him after the game
[Laughter]
oh my god so that was a water slip yeah
man it looks like someone's just swept
their feet boom
okay that one is even way worse
like way more embarrassing if that was
joy behard her body she would have just
disintegrated when she hit the floor
shattered like
fine china
yeah broken into a million pieces
oh look at the mascot the bird is like
what do i do look at this
clippers
106.
all right that's pretty good
just saying
an australian spider-man oh
spider-man but yeah
yeah i mean what's the difference
austrian australian a big difference
you'll see in this video
spider-man
takeouts are usually pretty bad
[Music]
what a [ __ ] guy dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's still playing
that's incredible
oh that's one of the best balls ever
he just he just totally surrenders to it
no way dude
oh no way he doesn't even try to fight
it you really got cause you keep
laughing understandably but listen to
the to his scream you make when he
impacts the wall it's the best cigarette
okay wait i gotta be cool now hang on
all right come on now what kind of
bobstagger am i play the button
are you sure that's him
but how is he still playing
and accordion like it makes noise when
it moves in and out and so you think
it's just sucking in air he's just
writhing in pain
and also like his hands are stuck in the
accordion there's traps
he can't he can't get his head down to
stop his fall
he's not chewing
he pushes it in dude he pushes it in he
goes well he's just the true
professional
look at
there he pushed it in yeah no he's still
going you're right never stop playing
yeah
right there
oh my god that's that's that's
incredible i saw that right before the
show and i was dying oh god
that's one of the best ones since the
turkish firefighters
[Music]
oh that's fantastic
sounding cordial makes when spider-man
loses his footing couldn't be any better
yeah the scream afterwards is great i
almost missed that
well you guys know we've been playing
elder elden ring a lot
so we did a lot that's an understanding
yeah
well anyway we've been talking about it
too and this morning i was playing at
work and you guys interrupted me
yeah i mean we trying to get things done
trying to start the show so
well anyway we filmed it so why don't
you just play it
okay one sec
[Music]
before storm gate
[Music]
i shall chase you back to castlemorn
[Music]
in the name of queen marika i shall be
your elden lord
i serve
god when the golden i am tarnished
rise tarnished
by the roots of the herb tree and the
lambs between
these nuts
i serve to protect
foul demon rat i shall [ __ ] in your open
mouth
[Music]
i'm gonna take a massive [ __ ] down your
throat you [ __ ] wench
they're [ __ ] 30 minutes late so
[ __ ] like they're throwing tomatoes
come on dude
i shall blood slash thee
[Music]
there are more demons he'll foot i shall
cleanse you for the grace
i gotta go he's covered
i shall strike you down in the name of
the beast's covenant
[Music]
get [ __ ]
we gotta do the podcast though anybody
got any res magic can we just can we
just put them in the chair
i'll like do a weekend at bernie's like
that yeah okay i'm just gonna try it
that works
you forget that wire
yeah
that's actually a good [ __ ] that's a
true story of class balance
i am i'm grinding my heart out trying to
be a good warrior and dan just cast his
[ __ ] lightning
that's how it is
yeah that's how it is though tell them
ring baby
if you guys are wondering where's ethan
klein videos
when i beat elder ring built they'll be
back they'll be back
uh
white claw gabe
he's got well we have new phrases to
pitch him yeah he's running a little
late but uh he'll drop in really yeah
i'll bring him in once once again okay
i'm really curious about what he's gonna
think about some of these
[Laughter]
um feel free to throw some out as well
we just brainstormed the other day so um
jake paul is fighting vladimir putin
he got a lot of backlash for this yeah
he did but why do people care about a
dumb joke
i don't know people always get mad about
everything but well what's the criticism
that he's just
um
he's trying to chase clout that putin
club this tweet is not it bro
i mean it's not that dumb joke but yeah
who cares angry
well people got super mad at me for
making jokes about cnn having applebee's
commercials i'm like guys
right
someone commented
on our last episode and said don't put
gunshots in the off the rails opening
right now
guys epic people are being shot
somewhere in the world all the time okay
unfortunately including me during the
beginning of off the rails
stop it
right
just when you think you i don't i get
you know in this case uh i just don't
see what's wrong with this dumb meme
i really don't other than it just being
dumb
yeah i mean that's the real that's the
real crime here i mean remember would
love to hate anything jake paul too so
sure but you know what's kind of ironic
is people are more mad about this meme
than about the
what the new york times wrote about him
that they don't care about
good point
okay not interesting great that one not
interesting not interesting um we're
already at 30 minutes into the show my
friend really we are dude that's crazy
you guys know steak the they're they run
by a shack and uh
in a cursor curiosal drake is doing a
huge partnership with them
steak is out of control how much money
they paying him he bought the shack they
gave him the shack he took the offer can
you pull up the photo of the wait am i
supposed to know what is steak yeah you
know we talked about it where twitch all
these twitches were being paid like
millions of dollars every month to
gamble and we're like dude this this
shit's shady
and then we looked up the address of oh
that's what the snake is yeah
it's the shed i love the sand yeah this
is this is steak's headquarters right
here
this is it that was one of the funniest
moments so on the podcast so drake has
decided to team up
no way with steak
and
they must well they were paying like aid
and ross you know over two million
dollars a month yeah or something like
like an aiden ross with peace and love i
mean
you know but drake on the other how much
they paying him
oh yeah i can't use that like that
like i've seen he's been playing a lot
on it too
um
jake's drake's worth like half a billion
dollars so
i just how much are they paying him to
make it worth it
50 million 100 million
just tells you how much money they're
just fleecing from people man yep and
you know he ain't playing with his own
money too
right
that was part of what we kind of
uncovered in all of that
two million views huh
that's wild
oh boy dude he lives in oh well he lives
in canada actually i think it's fine
there
true so right
except for the fact they don't pay
people out i wonder if he knows what
their office looks like
yeah baby like my house he lives yeah
he's got like the most expensive house
yeah
yeah baby yeah we should send drake
pictures of steak headquarters
in fact i wonder if we could get it
trent like you know how
well i want to get i do need to point
out that we did find out though that we
were wrong that shaq wasn't the real
shack right it was a shack across the
street exactly
it was actually a little bit nicer than
the one it was painted it was the same
shack essentially but painted by the way
i just googled it it's funny because
they were all used they were using it as
like a gotcha they were like oh
that's not the shack here's the real
shack i was like oh okay that's much
better i google image stake headquarters
and i'm not disappointed
here it is it's actually this check no
but it actually shows these uh
this is the headquarters of the billion
dollar gambling empire my friends i
think this was the real yeah i think
that blue yeah i remember the blue uh
thing being part of general catering no
well there's like next to it or
something i remember the blue
roof but maybe it was another shack that
looked like that i don't know it had
like a little fence around there yeah
there was a fence around
grass
this is nice so
this is nice
nothing wrong with that
yeah jerry google steak headquarters my
dude
just to know who you're working with
there
that was awesome
anyway let's do our sponsors
we got plenty more to talk about
so thank you first of all to men
mobile
you know um
you love them
they're changing and shaking up the
mobile game if you're looking to save
money
save more spend less when your top goals
for 2022 why are you still paying
insane's amounts of money every month
for wireless switching to mint mobile is
the easiest way to save this year and as
the first company to sell premium
wireless services online only mint
mobile lets you maximize your savings
with plans starting at just fifteen
dollars a month dan talk to us about how
much you love mint mobile and don't hold
back
uh i love it uh
it's a ten it's a ten out of ten baby
that's it that's my level of love that's
right
nice
same thing dude it's but cheaper it's
the same thing but cheaper whatever
you're using one of the big guys you
know who we're talking about big bad
guys big bad wolves and a mobile
industry
don't use them use my mobile instead for
people looking for extra savings this
year mobile offers premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month am i going online
only eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile passes significant
savings onto you all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network use your own phone with any
mobile plan and keep your same number
along with all your existing contacts
and with mint mobile choose the amount
of monthly data that's right for you and
stop paying for data that you never use
switch to mint mobile and get premium
wireless services starting at just 15
bucks a month and to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get this plant shipped right to your
door for free go to
mintmobile.com after dark that's
midmobile.com after dark cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
after dark thank you thank you thank you
and up next is a fun one talking about
the boys the new animated show
some of the most unhinged and maniacal
minds in hollywood today comes
diabolical a collection of eight
irreverent
and emotionally shocking animated short
films
episodes range from 12 to 14 minutes and
are each stylistically different oh wow
yeah it's kind of like uh if you've ever
seen the animatrix or one of those sort
of uh
uh compilation i love that series it's
that for the boys universe how fun
the first one is called i'm your pusher
which is an homage to the original boys
comic
the second one is an animated short
where
pissed off supers soups kill their
parents rick and morty justin royal in
aesthetic
yeah he's involved in this
yes
are you serious
oh that's freaking awesome there's a lot
of really cool people involved there's
an anime inspired one nubia vs nubian
laser boys day out classic looney tunes
short john and son he korean drama anime
[ __ ]
a bbf's inspired by pokemon boyd in 3d
french comics animation style oneplus
one equals two
it's an anime inspired
so that sounds great
i mean it's all on
uh
it's all on amazon so you already have
access to it just go watch it although
the series is set in the world of the
boys you do not need to watch the boys
to enjoy these series series uh features
a star-studded voice casting team
including
writers from the boys invincible rick
and morty
aquafica
aquafica dan cheetah chance crawford
i was like are you trying to design
[Music]
not to be a dick but she has the same
name as that water
i don't think anybody's ever pointed
that out before it's just confusing i
mean who came first aquafino or aquafina
we got it with some one needs to settle
on a new name
which factory like that who came first
aquafina or aquarium
the water definitely came the water came
the water came first yes well she got no
business name in her and her parents got
no business with i don't think that's
standing that name out i don't think
that's her real name
i think well i don't actually so was she
a rapper or something she just make up
crazy names like that
um who else is
who else is in the series i don't know i
don't recognize these names justin
roiland seth rogen andy sandberg don't
recognize his names i skipped a bunch
okay
um christian slater kevin smith simon
pegg keenan
and i skipped a bunch that i don't know
so peace and love
uh anthology so anyway go check it out
how to make the boys universe even
bloodier okay
didn't ask for that
uh like this the boys present diabolical
an animated series now streaming on
prime video
click the link in description or just go
watch it in prime thank you
fun uh
i'm seeing on google that aquafina was
born in 1988 and the company was founded
in 1994.
so they say that again that she was born
in 1988 and the company was founded in
1994. and then is that her right but
that's not you also said what is she a
rapper or something she actually okay
does and no that is not what's her mate
what's her birth name nora loom okay
that makes sense
i'll let it slide
yo i drink that like aquafina refreshing
i wonder if she does like a bunch of
water rhymes with her name
refreshing like aquafina
i'm trying to feed you some fresh
aquafina
we actually have talked about her on the
show uh in one of those marvel yeah
she's one of the marvel one about being
in um
yeah that's her that's aquafina yeah no
i know who she is
i just always thought i was just always
confused by the whole damn aquafina name
i've always known who aquafica is
yeah
that's what you said the first time you
read it
i know who she is
what do you want from me you need to
know everything at all
this has been very confusing
for life
all right moving on
ben chic
ben shapiro's in the news uh shibimo
shiben shibibo gives a horrible kurt
cobain analogy apparently
um
shout out to def for this one
okay so that is what he had to say on
ukraine then he got into the bad part of
his speech okay that was the best part
of his speech then he got how does
anybody watch him i don't know i'm sorry
to already pause but he is so obnoxious
and like
his audience are like weird alpha red
pill conservatives and he's like the
most beta
person alive
this is the bad part so you started
talking about the pandemic and this is
where the lies begin because when you're
the president of the united states and
you've had the worst 14 months of any
president of the united states ever
abraham lincoln had a full-scale
insurrection on his hands in the
beginning of his administration that
wasn't caused by abraham lincoln
everything bad that has happened over
the last 14 months is a completely
self-inflicted wound
okay joe biden is the cobain of politics
he put a shotgun in the mouth of the
american body politic and then pulled
the trigger what
bro that was so for that was so
unnecessary
why would you say that
that reminds me of the nba announcer
who's like just like his dad
at least that one was a great shot
why did you say that you dumb [ __ ]
what even possessed you to say something
like that exactly
joe biden is the kurt cobain of politics
he put a shotgun in his mouth in america
and pulled the trigger and the brains
are on the wall holy [ __ ]
ben
what is wrong with you
jesus christ
that's a good point
yeah he's wet ass p-word
yeah he didn't kill anybody else that's
a horrible analogy
right
yeah on top of on top of everything so
he conjured it and it's not even an
accurate comparison
and the worst beginning of a presidency
of any president like i mean there's
been like
multiple presidents who have been killed
in the first like wasn't there a
president got killed like on his third
day well there was harrison who died
from the flu like 20 days into his
presidency so he probably had a worse
first one in the first
beginning as well
did our we could all we could be
showering in gold right now and he'd be
like this is the worst presidency of all
time okay
it's like kurt cobain uh
some people think he was assassinated
some people think that his wife killed
it some people think he killed himself
it's like that nobody knows what's going
on
everything comes back to kurt cobain
it's like that song that came before
it's just smells like team spirit it's
like that it's pretty good but like you
know is it as good as we thought it was
i don't know it's like that
you guys want to do um
oh wait you guys want to talk [ __ ] about
the elden ring clips i've been sending
in group chat
no
you just went out of order and talked
already did art set up the alden ring
yeah okay well
i want to watch it
alright guys this is my new shield with
the talisman watch this now by the way
you guys do not have permission to share
this this is a private video i sent
here i made it
i made ila record and send you guys to
show you how badass my build is with the
talisman watch this every attack stuns
the enemy
and by the way oh i was doing this fight
last night
it was really easy right
uh
i
got to it and died and went to sleep
this was at like 2 30 in the morning oh
really well i'll have to give it like by
the way it looks like i'm not doing
damage
i'm invincible he can't do anything to
me
that's it thanks for watching my thanks
for watching my
video okay here's an example oh there's
another one if it was up on the wall
just to show you what we're dealing with
so we we hang out in the basement and um
now we got two tvs up can you see the
other one in the previous one you could
so what's the volume situation like
i just turned mine down a lot thanks for
watching
thanks for watching another example of
my awesome power i just peed in my
basement
do you need sound for the game
it's nice but it's not a big deal i
don't mind oh yeah i mean nathan does
sacrifice it for
the greater for me i think so i
appreciate it wow yeah for the greater
good
but we installed a tv so we could hang
out together because i was just playing
elder ring there's a picture of it in
the dark the next link so i got a i got
a we got a second tv
so that we can because if not it's like
we got to be a sad couple and like i
have to watch upstairs and he's playing
downstairs right it's fun i like
watching so we got the
the uh salt lake city by the way
oh my god the housewives of salt lake
city the best yes it's their union right
now
anybody out there watching
it's the best i need you all to watch
that show i don't know how many ways
like nobody watches it it's like their
lowest rated one and it's by far it's so
good these women these are the
collection of the most crazy women all
together you've never met one person
like this and they managed to bring like
five people together like this they're
so [ __ ] crazy and it is so insanely
entertaining i mean these are
lunatics they are not even close to sane
and the way that they bicker and get in
fights they're throwing drinks at each
other they're screaming it's like wwf
but real life yeah one of them got
arrested for tax fraud one of them is
running like a crazy we talked about
that on the show yeah bro they were
going on an outing and literally the fbi
came and [ __ ] arrested her
and actually it was even more shitty
than that she got a call from someone
who they still don't know who it was and
she's like oh my my uh
my dad's in the hospital or no my
husband's in the hospital i have to go
and then she bounces real fast and then
the fbr come and they're like yo where
is she someone talk about security
homeland security it's crazy and then
she stays on the show
and like they have interviews with her
and with or they show her talking to the
lawyer like it's crazy to be able to
witness all that well and then and then
the women start get they have this
conspiracy theory about they think one
of the girls on the show is an informant
and they start arguing about it oh crazy
they're
always drunk yeah
they were way off when they were blaming
her for
um they were blaming meredith for like
being in on it oh that's so crazy it was
like a total i'm telling you guys
there's nothing like this i'm seeing a
lot of people in the chat saying yes
they're they're all about this show as
well so you're okay you're not alone i'm
just i'm saying if i want to be
entertained
housewives of salt lake city
the best um the the mary cosby yeah she
didn't show up
such a bummer that's the that's the
church lady mary cosby's the head of
some crazy-ass church it's basically a
cult she was another cast member there
and this woman is so mean she goes this
one girl she walks in
from visiting her aunt who is in the
hospital and she goes oh you smell like
hospital and it started like this huge
multi-episode fight
where she's like you told me like you're
in the hospital basically like the whole
season they were fighting over that
and then this one other girl
her husband is so desperate to have more
kids he goes well he goes well if you
don't want more kids then i'm gonna have
to get a sister wife
okay and
they already have like uh how many two
or three two or three they have two
together i think but she already had
like eight miscarriages she had eight
miscarriages so you would think the guy
would be more sensitive he's like i need
more kids she's like honey i'm i'm over
40. i can't have more kids i don't want
to deal with that he goes well then i'm
going to have to get a sister wife
you've got to see this people to believe
it sounds juicy and this guy's a
chiropractor
every episode absolutely
and then this guy's a chiropractor and
he's just babies
he is just awesome babies what he did to
one of the other housewives apparently
damn he adjusts baby wait that's um
you're
are you mixing now you're mixing the
housewives of miami oh no i am you're
right right i can't mix my house
i don't care i don't care about miami
it's all about i watched it look i got
so hooked on salt lake and then like
between episodes i'm like having
withdrawals so now i watch housewives
with miami
i watched the housewife's ultimate trip
that one's pretty good pretty good and
now i'm i've decided i'm gonna get into
the new york one and we started from
like season one episode one those women
are so
obnoxious
they're talking about like if you wanna
raise in status in new york city
it's all about being in the right it's
like these i can't believe these people
are real they're actually absolutely
wait you didn't tell them the craziest
part about mary i want to see their
reaction go ahead
she's what you're saying she's
crazy you want me to say yes
married
she married her dad not that grandpa or
her grandpa grandfather
this man was married to her grandma who
was like the head of this church
and then in her will she says if you
want to inherit my wealth and the church
you have to marry my husband she's
married to her [ __ ] grandpa not
biological right step step grandpa
and like dude i'm just saying like and
then they get invited and they're like
at least i'm not [ __ ] my grandpa
unbelievable
it's unbelievable
this woman's [ __ ] her she's she's
married to her grandpa you guys oh
they're saying orange comedy is a good
one
i believe that was actually the original
that's how it started how do you know
that i just looked it up yesterday ally
watches all the time oh okay oh god i
gotta go but she doesn't actually watch
the salt lake city one and i i've been
telling her that you guys are always
talking about how this is
i've never seen this much women together
in one place unbelievable i've already
taken my pants off
you guys
it's so entertaining bro elden rings and
uh
just put it on the background yeah
we do the same thing my monitor is right
next to the tv so yeah yeah okay this
person is saying new york is the
craziest i do get that feeling
well we got
i think i can't follow the lives of like
a hundred different women because
there's so many of these
yeah i just got to pick a lane and ride
it to the end
you know i've been uh shocked are you
guys watching 90 day at all i have i've
not been caught up with this season oh
my god is it a good one insane dude
or before 90 days
yeah it's it's the craziest i've ever
seen
like
i've been wanting to but i'm not getting
through it yeah
where do you watch it on 90 days you
know
there's this guy gino and it's just the
funny [ __ ] like he refuses to take his
hat off
oh is that the guy oh i saw that clip
actually it's like a bald guy who's
trying to he's with that girl in like
south america yeah he got into a giant
fight and she's [ __ ] screaming at him
and she rips the hat off and you take
the [ __ ] stupid hat off and he turns
around and reaches into a bag and grabs
another identica
he's got like backups
i
wait let's pull it up let's pull it up
we
give me that hat scene somebody pulled
that up okay people are also saying uh
and sorry if i'm not saying it right but
potomac or how do you say that city yeah
that's why i have so much
that's it's it's like washington d.c
i i mean i haven't seen it but i would
guess that i would guess that that's
really [ __ ] nuts i'm the wife of uh
senator exactly
politicians wives and stuff that'll get
real wild can you do a poll which ones
we should watch like well they're so
[ __ ] the polls restricted to four
options yeah
the thing about the salt lake city one
two is that a lot of these women are
ex-mormons and the insight to how crazy
the mormons are is really interesting i
love that like the mormons are really
they're very hateful they are like yeah
heather like the heather i love her by
the way she's so nice and um her story
they want to like came out of mormonism
dude they're so cruel like if you [ __ ]
up they just cut you out into the
wilderness yeah should i do four that
you guys haven't seen like the potomac
yeah do that
uh atlanta atlanta and orange county i
want to get you know it'd be cool if we
could just
the beverly hills one oh
yeah
there's just no no season right now okay
i wonder if we get andy cohen on it
who is that he's the guy he's the guy
he's the man behind all of us i love him
he's the man i love him i got to get me
some andy cohen on the show now
is there wait there's is there another
one potomac oc new york and what is
there guys
atlanta there's two men atlanta atlanta
okay atlanta okay i'm doing a poll we'll
see what you guys should focus on next
i think i spelled atlanta wrong so
forgive me
yeah um
oh and then dude i'm telling you these
salt lake city ladies so the other
family is like strict mormons and guess
what they own a [ __ ] alcohol company
but they don't drink they're not allowed
they're not allowed to drink alcohol but
they sell alcohol that's amazing that's
just so fun and she's the crazy she's so
sick yes all right
it is neck and neck between new york and
atlanta those two are
basically tied uh okay
so i think our journey on the new york
one is good i think we should stick with
that
okay good new york yeah i watched the
first step i was like man these ladies
are not so i've learned that like if i
try to just
start on a new season it really sucks
because you don't know all the like lore
of every character
so i'm starting from the beginning yeah
oh man
salt lake city so good
[Music]
okay and then one of the girls in salt
lake city hired a private investigator
to investigate another one
[Laughter]
and then one of the other ones uh her
son is gay and she goes all the time on
twitter and talks [ __ ] about her son
being gay
on the show
calling out the other lady's son yeah
yeah she's going these people are crazy
when he like never came out yet
yeah she she outed his son on twitter
in between seasons
called him like a [ __ ] f word or
something like super nasty
see then
y'all got to watch it anyway
by the way on the housewives times of
miami
there's one pretty crazy story but yeah
i don't know if people are over it i'll
hear it
uh there's alexia i was telling you
about her
her um
father
apparently she said died
afterwards they found out that he was
secretly gay okay
her father and then her
same thing happened to her with her
husband oh that's so interesting
he died and then later after she found
out he was gay and he had a lover
and she goes and talks to his lover
and like
she's happy for him that he was happy
that's so weird like it's so crazy they
say you look for people like your
parents but how could you even like
find a secretly gay man that's just
crazy anyway here's this clip i was
thinking of a different guy so this is
new for me
this is the scene from 90 day where
apparently the guy has a backup hat yeah
your breasts are showing that's correct
but they're not nudes
so take off
them
and finally do you know oh he really
doesn't like oh cause look at that tan
line bro
like never takes it off so this guy's
let's find him he's a he's kind of a
piece of [ __ ] this guy because he he
sent nude photos of the girl he's with
to his former ex
to like rub it into like style on his ex
yeah like look how hot my girlfriend is
or whatever and you did it without her
permission yeah and she found out about
it and [ __ ] went off yeah
damn his head is like has no tan though
he looks like a
you gotta see the back he looks like an
uncircumcised penis head or something
like you see the foreskin right here
yeah thanks gets off the bed like a
scary okay like
all of the i was looking too okay
but stupid commentary videos well if you
can't talk peacefully then
oh my god
he refuses he'll sleep with it on him
it doesn't look that bad now like
without it it's really insecure i mean
it doesn't look bad without it the only
reason he looks maybe goofy is because
of the
the tan line is crazy but it's not like
yeah keem syndrome i think that's the
psychological yeah
but you got to embrace it bro i saw
comments with people being like yo i
embraced my dome because of dan yeah
then made it cool shout out
embrace the dome embrace the dom
got your hat
[Laughter]
embrace the dome
all right guys we're moving on here
amaranth friend of the show hold on one
second
what happened
um before we move on to the next story
uh i just wanted to
[Applause]
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
what you doing
i'm hanging out the golf course baby oh
you're golfing
no i don't go i'm just looking again
just hanging out because it knows i'm
the king baby
yeah you run that golf course
i wish i'm the king baby
so you so you don't play you're just
you're just hanging out with people that
play
i'm just hanging out letting these
arrogant peasants know that i'm the king
baby
wow [ __ ] them
yeah yeah gabe you will you go tell one
of the peasants your king
i'm the king baby
i'm a genuine baby
now i promised you that we would have
some new
pitches to you for phrase ideas can we
pitch some to you
sure sure all right let's go one by one
so
this is nothing futs
nothing [ __ ]
nothing [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
well you make it sound good
outside i can improvise this is [ __ ]
fun
this is [ __ ] fun
uh i'm all i'm all-wheel drive baby
oh we drive [ __ ]
he makes it work he does good yeah yeah
when he says it uh how about uh
plow me like the snow
tommy
tommy like the snow [ __ ]
i can use that something like that plow
me like the snow yeah
cur how about this curdle my milk daddy
cuddle my mouth daddy
oh that's interesting
that one's kind of surprising
yeah
that is okay how about ouchy ouchy baby
i'm on fire what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
but yeah
ouch
i'm on fire [ __ ] yeah yeah
it works it works when you say it man
like that how about
blow out my back baby
my back
how about juggle these nuts [ __ ]
chuckles these nuts [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's good you like that
you know how about i sh
[ __ ] on my own floor
i [ __ ] on my own floor [ __ ]
that's a lot of ideas
yeah just you know we came right and
we're
we're workshopping here we'll you know
i [ __ ] on my own floor that's kind of
funny because i think you want to shock
people and just
kind of surprise the world
shock the world yeah
i don't know if you like any of those
that could work i could use some of
those phrases in some ways
maybe we should pick one like [ __ ] on
the floor
ouchy ouchy baby ouch ouchie ouchie i'm
a buyer
maybe i could use that
out
[Laughter]
wow
see he brings the magic holy when you
read the page it's not that impressive
yeah when it comes out of his mouth
we got to get this man in julia arts
that was incredible
well listen
shut up dan
you're on a roll julie sharks
juilliards
juilliard
all right you want to go talk to some of
the golfers and see tell them you're
king
no i'm going to want to bother that yeah
yeah yeah scary
i wouldn't ask you to do that i'm just
i'm just
all right well it's great to check in
with you hope you have a great friday
you can go back some white claws or what
probably
some dudes and parents and
start the night friday night maybe [ __ ]
that's right party or something good
luck baby
[Music]
what are you eating for dinner tonight
let's say fried chicken fried chicken
friday or sushi yeah baby
that's a good night that's a good night
friday baby good night
good night friday
fried chicken friday babe hey
are you wearing matching uh pants
oh i got just just the top
just the top and in jeans
you should consider that that would be a
look yeah
oh yeah
that could work too [ __ ] they [ __ ] yeah
all right gable i'm sure you're gonna
have an amazing weekend it seems like
you never miss on the weekend you never
miss on any day you're out there
yeah so try so i'm looking forward to
hopefully seeing one of these i hope one
of you liked uh liked one and anyway
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] woo baby
on my back baby
[Music]
ouch
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we'll see you next week thanks
a lot all right next week baby all right
bye bye [ __ ] baby see you on friday
[Music]
what a guy
the long awkward pause
i was ready to let it run i was gonna
let it ride for a while i was really
enjoying the bird sounds in the
background peaceful
yeah beautiful
so um
we were just about to talk about
amaranth you guys know she's been on our
show you know who she is the hot tub
girl
uh she's selling her farts now and once
again i just want to say
that this was my idea
do you guys give me credit i remember it
okay do you all remember it too yeah
maybe a fan can help because we looked
you couldn't find with the when we
interviewed her we also
no it was um maybe it was uh when we
were talking about belle
said she should but i should usually can
her fart yeah yeah so it's too deep of a
cut we wanted to pull the clip it's time
to show the proof but
yeah it was when she was like the first
to sell her bath water yeah right maybe
even before the bath water i'll be
honest maybe because i remember even
being like this was my idea right oh
that's all my idea
so thick so true she says i started new
business have you ever wanted to smell
your favorite streamer's own hot tub
water
wait
have you ever wanted to smell your
favorite streamer
or own their hot tub water
well where's the farting part let's go
to the melio favorites
so cutie patooties so the website's very
simple by amaranth so the website is
very funny
for the most part it's graphic well for
the most part okay
there are one or two photos in there
though that are okay so probably too
much i'm just going to click here to buy
now i just want to say oh god did you
show that no we're not showing okay
thank god
i just wanted to see the product
okay so kind of find a part you want to
show and then say okay let's show this
so much for not showing that no we
discussed this before it's just so
graphic it's almost like you guys know
what you're doing back there yeah we
have been bold lettering warning graphic
do not show
we also briefed this morning ian don't
show
at least
i remember here let me get this off this
i remember oh my god okay hold on
people saying it's in the episode with
hassan in the hot tub i think you did
mention it on the in the crack
but
um it it definitely goes further back
then oh it goes way better so but but
that's a direct line of her possibly
getting the idea interesting jumping in
the hot tub the cracker hot tub with me
i'm just saying yeah i'm an ideas man
you are unexpected without a doubt
innovator do you think i'm an an ideas
man
for sure yeah of course you are thank
you guys
idea machine
yeah thank you so much
you're less of an execution guy nope
but the ideas part you've got it around
1am 2am
oh yeah those ideas start flowing
right exactly
i'm just getting started so now this is
smart a thousand dollars so you know
it's genuine
genuine since you're saying that weird
on purpose
yeah i did
the scent jar by amaranth have you ever
want to know what your favorite streamer
smells like now is your chance
with the super exclusive edition scented
fart
made especially by amaranth for you
includes one scent filled jar
made exclusively to order
with a real human hair
easter is autographed and hand numbered
from one to a thousand
okay each jar has made the order that's
how it's done okay so this is so they've
just found it now this is just from
december
yeah am i muted hold on let me pull up
my audio this is real interesting guys i
didn't even if that makes the value go
up i'll do anything to him
i wouldn't say so
i mean if it's sat on tell you i mean
you you're free to take over oh jar of
rich crackers that amaranth has sat on
maybe fart on them fart on would you
fart on crackers and sell it i mean if
that makes the value go up i'll do
anything okay so it's close it's not
exactly the fart but it's farted on
crackers so yeah i would say not quite i
mean i've been talking about farting
it definitely goes better for a while
yes for sure for sure it's kind of my
thing i think you need a cut of this man
that's what i'm saying five percent and
i want my own jar too
i don't want a jar i'm doing it do we
need to reach out and get one
i mean it would be nice for this for the
i think we got to make someone i mean if
it was your idea yeah
i mean the spit is dried up now so i
mean we need something new oh yeah did
we talk about that on the show yeah oh
in the move it like leaked and it's it's
yeah yeah yeah so the uh the iconic
jar bell delphine sent us of spit
is all dried up
it still smells just like my dreams
that's
right so each jar comes hand autographed
and numbered
so do you guys think she's actually
farting i mean i hope she is for a
thousand also i wonder if she's selling
these
still not sold out okay go off the
screen now because i have to go back
thank you
so graphic
and then the other one's just hot tub
water i mean
okay
that's you know
been there
the fart jar is the real innovation
but i'm glad someone's taking my ideas
and i'm glad to see it's actually doing
work for her yeah
i mean she's not the first too
just how far she is yeah who sells soap
farts the 90 day fiance
girl no way we have that yeah yeah we
talked about it she ended up in the
hospital
no [ __ ] wait wait we talked about
that all right i remember maybe i don't
know if it made it
wait she sold so many farts that she
ended up in the hospital i actually
they did put it in the document in case
you do wait she uploaded a video for
showing wait hold on can i watch this
video yeah yeah it's that she doesn't
actually fart it just shows how she and
she's not like in a thong or anything no
no no no okay so here we go
oh wait wait wait wait
i thought you were talking about the 90
day girl
goddammit
there's a whole section well it says she
upload a video showing what goes into a
jar of farts so what so you were talking
about that yeah but this one doesn't say
warning graphic so can i watch it i
think you should be okay then yeah okay
thank you let's try again let's find out
amaranth let's roll the dice
it's on youtube it can't be that bad
right i don't like the name put
patooties cutie patooties but it was a
great name i think it's too cute i just
want it to be called fart in a jar well
i don't like the cute the cutification
of it but
you know i don't know that guys would
buy it it was like
well i mean guys are [ __ ] nasty
though i don't know
to me cutie patooties is more disgusting
than fart in a jar this is a clever pun
because you don't want to make it cute
like it's just makes me want to be
debased
you know what i mean i want to feel
disgusting
um well the next phase is just [ __ ]
in a jar
you could probably sell it for 10 000.
somebody funny you just said that i just
looked over the chat farah from teen mom
sold her [ __ ] in a jar no seriously no
i'm just
a [ __ ] swiped cotton ball
how much for uh
yeah that's scary
to research this you cannot send human
[ __ ] through the us postal store oh yeah
let's not forget our candle
yeah it smells like butthole that dude
that was artificial that thing sold the
[ __ ] out are we bringing that back for
the holidays again oh we should it's
march
plan ahead yeah saint patrick's day
butthole camp
we got a plan for the holidays okay well
i'm not sure
because
this one's sold out free order sales
were nine dollars
for the poop wait just nine bucks for a
swab of [ __ ]
what a good deal
dude the world is so [ __ ] crazy
horrible wait hold on hold on hold on
okay
wow
using her daughter to throw shade on the
internet
this is sophia's merch site oh wait so
is it a joke or something it looks like
a joke it looks like yeah it looks like
poopy slime
what she says she's using her daughter
to throw shade on the internet
i guess i don't know the lore
yeah
poopy slime ages 5 plus
wait so where did you get the idea of a
cotton swab of [ __ ]
i just i read a comment i think yeah i'm
just going off of the chat i didn't know
anything about this this was just info
coming to me from the chat
i'm trying to piece together this i
think what dan was talking about was
going around on the internet so she put
this out
as
trolling back the troll apparently she
spelled her own name wrong
it has two r's just saw it in the cut
okay so then she didn't sell her own
poop
well that's disappointing damn that is
disappointing that is just so
disappointing
all right well let's see anyway back to
farting in the jar
the whole hair thing is weird man
[Music]
but can she
is she gonna fart right now
no she's just showing is it showing how
can you make sure you
she farted a little bit
how can you tell you heard it yeah yeah
i heard it yeah it's just a little
squeaker yeah maybe with headphones you
can hear well
yeah so can you write her we're going to
need one of these
i i think i think it's only right i
don't know
who's going to smell it we'll reach out
we'll figure out not me
right why are you cutting to me
[Laughter]
zach you gotta smell it okay it's only a
one thing too like the bell delphi and
we could all pass it around yeah but the
fart is a one shot one kind of thing
i'm doubting it's even gonna smell like
farts like i mean this is not a
commitment it's not and
i mean
i don't know if
i mean in the video it doesn't sound
like that gnarly of a fart
so
for for a thousand bucks she better be
like she wouldn't be eating beans
exclusively for the next month so yeah
read the uh the next story
oh okay because i guess you don't i
think we did talk about it but you don't
remember it
yeah no yeah i think we didn't talk
about it on the show
so okay
the farts are going for a thousand
but now we go so 90 day fiance stef
stephanie matto
i wish i knew who she was because i
stopped watching around the time of big
ed she was on that season
okay wait let me pull up a photo before
we get into the story because this is
really good
um stephanie mato
this girl selling her farts no i
remember her
she doesn't seem like that much of a
degenerate to be selling her farts but i
guess
who is she with she was with like a
weird
um she was with the the girls she had uh
purple hair and she lived in australia i
believe
i remember was she like super that was
an annoying story was that the storyline
she was like super insecure she was okay
yeah
yeah i don't i don't remember liking her
yeah well so anyway
she claims to have made over a hundred
thousand dollars selling farts
she later stopped selling them for
health reasons after experiencing a
heart attack
how do you fart that much
her health problems were caused by
eating too much gas inducing foods like
protein shakes and exactly what you just
said i admire i really appreciate your
commitment to value yeah cause i'll tell
you those amaranth jars they're not
gonna
it ain't gonna be like that you don't
know that
trust me i saw what she did
i need i want pink eye from opening that
job
since she can't
sell physical farts anymore she moved to
selling nft fart jars you know that's
not gonna work so there's a tick that's
not gonna fly
yeah i got it here what is this oh my
gosh okay so this is the nft's but
there's one above it um in the dock that
it shows what she was eating in a day
okay yeah
let's
see hey guys today i'm going to be
showing you a day in the life of a girl
who sells her farts in a jar so i like
to get things rolling with some beans a
protein muffin sometimes even a yogurt
less sugar is better
some hard-boiled eggs and today i
decided i was going to make myself a
protein shake with snacks
the whole unbuckled thing
i like to read i'm very
smart and then after i'm ready to go i
go ahead and
do my work do my job i don't want to
show you that guys but i like to add in
little flower petals i feel like they
attach the scent and make it last longer
and when i'm finally finished
with my jar i like to leave a
personalized
i want to thank you so much the 97 wow
she's delivering just one comment she
had a fart attack
a fart attack very good very good
that's good
yo she puts a freaking rose petal in
there and a personal note that's
commitment
you know that's that that's an american
quality
as american quality made in the usa
ships worldwide
organically produced
non-gmo
green initiative
bad for uh it's actually bad for climate
change
departing yeah the farting is not good
for climate change too much methane
gotta cut down with those
well well well that's a whole there's a
whole vertical going on here
yeah i'm reading now that maybe
that pharah the teen mom did
poop
i need to know if this woman pooped and
sold or pooped or what yeah like give me
the details supposedly there was a video
on only fans of her demonstrating how it
works how she does it she's gonna poop
in a jar
and then send it but the video has since
been ripped and i can't find it anywhere
um no
who's this what's your name the one
the teen mom pharah
fairway abram abraham
okay
and she's a mom
a teen mom apparently
yeah so this is what happens when the
teen mom money runs out yeah
you start selling your own [ __ ]
god she has only fans too eh
yeah she works in the adult film
oh okay that's great so wait was that
she became an adult after yeah and
that's why supposedly mtv didn't take
her back
okay interesting
all right well she's because of that
one of the house ladies is only fans too
she says she makes 10 she says she makes
10 000
that's um households of miami yeah yeah
and all the other girls are all
judgmental in maine tour it's awesome
10 grand a day yeah damn i know
jesus and she doesn't even do nudes
apparently
but she
she's gonna like
some people were calling her out on it
because she's kind of putting out this
like
i'm single and um lots of guys message
me so maybe i'll find somebody like that
i don't know she goes i get messages
from truckers i'm downstream as long as
you're a good trucker i'm open like i
want to make guys on my only fans like
trying to get people to sub sure and
people started calling her out she was
married to scottie pippen she's not
looking for a truck driver
is a name larsa yeah okay okay
are you subscribed
no no no
i know that was his ex-wife
yeah it's his ex-wife oh man i'm telling
these shows are unbelievable i need andy
cohen who's who's going to message him i
got it there's actually a little uh
update on that i don't want to give too
many details away but a fan who is
watching uh messaged and hooked it up
with the contact info oh come on andy
we're your biggest fans
we really live i don't want to out this
person but you know who you are thank
you for sending every time thank you
every time we watch our reunion we're
like andy's so good because he's so good
he asked like all the questions that you
wish you would ask
it's just andy
come on
uh just to protect us from a potential
lawsuit the hollywood gossip reported
that that's why mtv fired her but i'm
not 100
okay
allegedly how would we know
how would we know
just reading articles here
well sue b don't sue me i didn't say it
i'm just kidding
you're protected thank you if you say
something i get sued soon
what's the kanye larsa tweet now i'm
curious people are saying talk about the
kanye larse tweet
kanye larson so larsa is a part of her
stories i guess she was best friends
with kim and some of the ladies make fun
of her because they say she won't want
to be kim
kim kardashian so i guess she
she said something about kanye i don't
know
ian thoughts
i don't know what you're can you guys
just look up uh larsa tweet
uh
what are you afraid of ian
[Laughter]
tony brown town check yourself right at
the door
all right anyway whatever whatever
whatever who gives a [ __ ]
literally
um
oh dude by the way we've been talking
about this guy rollo tony browntown this
red pill guy who's been trying to
insert himself into our show and then he
made a video like what are you guys
afraid of well we figured out this is
like one of the most iconic memes in
internet history that just shows the
utter downfall and patheticness of red
pill males so look at this here's a
there's a statue
this guy tweets it out dark triad man uh
you can imagine what's his shtick
this is called art this is the legacy
and heritage of the west this is what
men of the west fight sacrifice and die
for this
is victory rollo tony browntown responds
to him is an example of a female
sculptor who committed herself to the
same level of detail that a male does
with a woman
and then ivan responds none that come to
mind
this sculpture is an act of worship
before heaven and it shows and then once
and then someone else came with the
facts the sculptor is a chinese woman
you tore cast
this is the creator i've seen this a
million times on the internet and i did
not put together that
he took one of the most uh
legendary ls
and he's trying to come here acting like
he's old that's our rolo that's our
that's our rolo yeah rational mail yeah
that's his the publication the rational
mail yeah what are you afraid of
by the way how did you do it yeah that's
incredible
the detail of the fabric is insane yeah
people were crazy with marble like but
the hair
yeah
yeah
i love that this is an all-time dunk wow
you dork ass losers
i mean
what pathetic losers you know
that's this is like basically red pill
uh ideology summarized
you know it's all based on assumptions
and just weird
[ __ ]
based on like their personal experience
of being freaks and getting rejected
from women i love that
all right so we want to have a
conversation now wait real quick
just because um
it turned out we can't show it on the
show because it got claimed but
a fan on the subreddit created a parody
version of the rolo tony song
about our roller tony that is the best
[ __ ] thing i've ever heard in my life
so how so what am i going to do about it
nothing but it's on our subreddit what
the hell i want to do with that
i just want people to see it all right
i'm shouting it out and letting it go no
name that's such a [ __ ] i know yeah yeah
it's so good it's it's awesome so go to
the sub find it it's it's amazing
so here's an article about ferris
selling her poop
siphara abram is selling her poop on the
internet
uh she became famous for getting friends
16.
get to the poop part did you read this
article
do you want me to we basically went over
most of it for you
so did you okay okay it's old i sent you
something
you just saw it okay
all right so um we're gonna talk today
about our biggest fears
our biggest fears
john you have a biggest fear
debt
just death
i mean that's terrible that qualifies
that's the best answer
what are you afraid about dying
oh i said debt
dead is a bigger fear than death
absolutely that's part of it
it's common whether you are you in debt
oh yeah
oh yeah you are we got a mortgage
oh okay wow
that's good yeah that's another out from
under everything else yeah
it took a bit
mortgage doesn't count as debt that's
good debt
yeah
so you're afraid of debt huh so what's
your worst case scenario
medical debt i get hurt in the garden
you know spear myself with a shovel or a
pickaxe or something um medical bills
it's just ruining anything you do a
billion dollars
yeah that's america
i was going to say are your people
[Laughter]
trying to keep your loved ones alive
that's america
that's america choosing between
your child potentially living and being
homeless in new york
that's america
that's america your mom is 75 years old
she doesn't have that many good years
left
that's america
that's america
let her die of cancer
let her die of cancer today
of diabetes or just affording to have
lunch
file for bankruptcy
for bankruptcy
yeah
oh that's a good fear sean because it's
actually just very possible oh that's a
good one absolutely uh if not that
probably uh snakes
oh yeah yeah you ever had a bad
encounter with the snake yeah i actually
did almost stepped on one going out the
backyard we got proper heads did you
freak the [ __ ] out it was a little one
but yeah for a minute i was
getting one of those the low ones are
more dangerous right because they can't
control themselves yeah yeah
well probably not poisonous
very boys copperheads are poisonous you
were almost stepped on a poisonous snake
yeah
oh what kind
i just told you copperhead oh it was
actually a copyright yeah i thought you
were just saying nobody said copperhead
we all did
you almost stepped on a copperhead those
are native out there yeah springtime
they're waking up right about now oh
[ __ ] that get my head on a swivel
copperhead bite what happens if you get
hit by a copperhead
copyrights have a hemotoxic venom
which means that a copperhead bite often
results in temporary tissue damage in
the immediate area of a bite the bite
may be painful but it's very rarely
fatal
children and elderly on that hand just
[ __ ] die from it
apparently and people will compromise
immune systems
yo
and like we said the the young ones they
don't know how to regulate how much
venom they get so in adult one you get
bit like you said it'll be very painful
but not necessarily fatal but a baby one
they'll just dump their entire uh
load of venom into you and
really [ __ ] you up you dump your load on
me down that's right
with my snake
[Laughter]
yeah that's that is scary if i had
copperheads in the garden no no no no no
no
i found a bunch of black widows in our
backyard when we met that i didn't like
but i don't think black widows really
bite people
i mean
they do but if they're not they're not
going to go out of their way too you
have to like be [ __ ] with them yeah
anything stupid if you or if you
accidentally walk into their web or
something but they're terrifying i mean
they look so scary they're scary yeah
they look creepy they're like jet black
with a red hourglass in the stomach it's
scary
have you visited blocked
um
on the show
have you
no never
well on the show
it's so funny
so that's actually thank you for sharing
sean
well that segues into mine because just
keep it on sean
thanks bro
yeah no it's just i'm like
we miss you
play the whole thing doc let it ride
okay
oh you just have it you have it reduced
he just has a view
okay who wants to go next how about the
young ian
besides being called to speak on kanye
what is your biggest fear
that's up there
um i mean spiders is up there but i know
that's kind of boring um
but i i have a lot of spider nightmares
and so really
yeah
a lot
okay um
that's a big one and that kind of
uh leads into my other like real
day-to-day fear which is like doing
something
that hurts myself when i'm asleep really
oh yeah it's still kind of a
ongoing thing now and again it's not as
bad as it was but it's it's still there
so for those of you who are unaware of
the ian lore
he has like really bad uh sleepwalking
issues to the point where you had to
like you get like tied down to the bed
right uh we were able to
remove the
the straps
from the equation so you had to do it
for a period of time
yeah
yeah i was i was uh tied down for a few
months that's easy it kind of went away
but um
my new thing that i've been doing is i
get up
and i spit
oh my goodness what
do you know what you're dreaming when
you're spitting
um
i have
dreams where
i feel like i've
there are like nails or thumbtacks in my
throat oh goodness
and so i will get up and i will go like
trying to get it oh my god and then sam
will wake up and see me over there just
going like
oh god yeah sam can you come comment on
this you're the most qualified i feel
like you could
you could write like a great horror
movie or something
yeah
well there was one really uh i remember
you really injured yourself kicking the
wall or something like you're trying to
defend sam right
uh yeah yeah that was definitely a
really bad time but it's not everything
to that again damn sam who made that
hoodie that thing's fire bro
show that off
damn let's go right now oh is that daddy
fred hi
oh by the way el tell what ellen john's
team
okay i want to read it yeah read it
but in the meantime sam
how's ian been doing with the sleeping
uh situation this man spitting
[Laughter]
um
the other day uh
with the trash can
oh yeah the other day i woke up and he
was there's like a little trash can in
our bedroom
and he was just like digging through it
and i don't know like what he was
looking for
he was digging through it and then he
just spit in it
but he always he spits on the floor more
than he spits in the trash can i just
wish you could make it to like the trash
so it's just like talking about that's
my request like
yeah is it big like mucousy ones or just
is it just a spit i've never noticed it
to be like muxy it's just like an alpaca
like
i guess so your fear is that you'll hurt
you or someone else and that that is
very scary because like you get i mean
like you really hurt yourself you almost
jumped out of a window once so
it's scary have you ever been scared by
him sam or you think he's fine
not recently i mean i take the spitting
and everything else over the punching a
hole in the wall
we've evolved past that point which is
great but yeah it's definitely not as
bad as it used to be but i used to be
that time where he punched a hole in the
wall i told him like don't feel bad
about this but that was one of the
scariest moments oh my god wow scary
so was he like in a rage when it
happened or he was just i think he was
having a nightmare he was having a
nightmare right yeah
yeah were you walking you were like uh
trying to protect sam now or was that
yeah
yeah i was having like
it's like that scene from star wars
where the they're getting compacted in
the thing yeah that's what i was
dreaming and sam was screaming at me to
stop
but that was in my dream and i thought
she was screaming like we're gonna die
the walls are gonna like smash us oh she
was saying stop to the wall
in my dream that's what i thought kind
of sweet sam he was he was yeah it was
all for you eh it was very sweet it was
also the first week i moved out here
what do you think part of the reason why
it was so bad ian was because you were
just kind of stressed about wanting to
put on a good impression and be
a good boyfriend
i mean there was a lot going on um
like i was moving we were apartment
hunting yeah i did this to the wall i
don't know if this will get our account
banned but this was at an airbnb
oh wow and uh we patched it up you know
oh you just patched it up
i never told the person about it well
who cares then good as deal you fixed it
yeah yeah at least
if you could punch through it it's not
like
it's whatever it is you did to it it's
fine yeah
yeah how about that huh and sam did you
ever think about leaving at all during
when he punched all in the wall during
your first week here
no but i was like if this happens again
you're like what did i get into yeah
holy crap it was literally like i had
been there for maybe seven days wow and
i was like oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i remember right after it happened
because sam
my lit my foot was broken
and
i was just covered in blood on my arm oh
my god and sam went to the bathroom kind
of she was like shell-shocked
and i remember sitting on the bed and it
was like that meme of the guy
pointing at himself oh you know like
your own enemy and i was sitting there
going like what have i done what have i
done
you're like
i mean you're tyler dirt and but not as
like interesting you just fight the wall
yeah i was actually like screaming at
him trying to wake him up because i i
had never
seen someone sleepwalk like that i
thought he was awake and just freaking
out and the neighbors actually like
called the cops oh [ __ ] because they
were freaking out like some like there
was a domestic dispute cause you were
screaming he's punching jesus yeah
yeah
but now i just spit
that's a lot better i mean that's a lot
better definitely yeah
well i'm glad you guys worked it out
yeah
thank you yeah
but you guys made it through something
like that that's uh
true love i think but now you get it you
know now you get it
that's a good one ian i mean that's
that's scary
i'm glad you're doing better thank you
so what was kanye been up to this week
though
that's going to be i'm going to have a
sleepwalking episode where i'm trying to
run from you
come back in we didn't talk about kanye
yeah come back
hold on do you have a jar
[Music]
how much do you think i could sell my
farts for god not a thousand
what if i put a a butt pube
in it she puts a hair i put a bun
valuable
you know guaranteed to smell bad too
unlike those girls
i don't know that one girl was eating
[ __ ]
hard work probably stunk like real beans
and yogurt give herself a heart attack
okay so you're ready
very good
uh oh yeah what do you got either this
is from elton john so from elton john's
team
they were really happy with the
how it all went and everything and they
said
they called the collection the best
elton john
merchandise ever
wow great work team tf
that's awesome
that's that is really awesome that's
dope that's crazy yeah that's really
nice
elton if you want to come on the show
doors open
around
yeah the game the proper title
sir elton john i love you
please come on the show
i'll even sign a partner for you
so who wants to go up next let's see
let's go with zachary
okay uh
pretty simple i guess
but
probably a deeper meaning as to why i'm
scared of it
um
birds
yep so that explains why you were
freaking out over the geese
well it's it's not like i was freaking
out over the geese i was freaking out
over their [ __ ]
no but you had like an irrational hatred
for geese bro i think it's just like all
birds in general okay that's interesting
so what's bro what happened with birds i
don't know but um
when i was younger like between four
through eight i was in occupational
therapy
because i mean my motor skills really
weren't like
advancing with my age
when you say motor skills does that mean
like talking walking yeah like i would i
couldn't like grab a ball properly i
couldn't that's interesting because
you're so you're such a talented guitar
player right it takes so much manual
dexterity yeah interesting that you were
under underdeveloped with that yeah so i
maybe that helped it i don't i don't
know but um
i would i was just i was in occupational
therapy and i i worked with this this
woman
for many years and she became family and
she helped me try and get over my fears
and do things and one of them was birds
but we tried going to a bird
park bird sanctuary and
i couldn't do it i freaked out mom so
what so paint the picture for me you're
at a bird sanctuary yeah is it one of
these things where it's like a big open
air cage yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so how
far into the sanctuary did you get or
did you i couldn't go through the door
like that
did you start crying and freaking out
yeah i i like did you run away yeah yeah
yeah because it was awful and i i can't
even go to like the farmer's market you
know like the grove
with all the pigeons and [ __ ] i can't do
it i just really like what about
seagulls
if i'm away from them at the beach and
that's fine but like if they're coming
up to me with like food when you're on
the beach i'm like nah gotta go sorry
and what's the scariest bird in your
opinion
[ __ ] crow or pigeon like i know it's
the pigeon is really not that
intimidating
if you look at it in retrospect but i
just hate the fluttering and like
my worst nightmare is having like a bird
on my head really it's not so much it
pecking at me it's just like fluttering
and [ __ ] what is it about the birds that
uh is are you repulsed are you scared i
i don't know what it is i um i don't
know so would you not go into a house
with someone who has like a bird oh [ __ ]
no i can't even go in that part
department at petco even if they're
caged nope can't do it
what if they're uh taxidermied
still freaks me out
something about the feathers i don't
know what it is what about like
what about
atypical birds like penguins or
ostriches that like aren't like
but they're like yeah flamingo exactly
no those don't bug me okay please don't
bug me so you gotta have me a standard
form factor a flying bird a flying right
like yeah exactly flamingos don't bother
you no i actually really enjoy flamingos
they also gave
the duck a green light too yeah ducks
are fine what yeah those are birds right
but those but they're more on it on my
head and i i can i can please say
something that the audience please don't
[ __ ] with me about this
wait you have a lot of sticks by the way
yeah you got a bird stick you got a
clear cleared i have a lot of
superstition i have superstitions and
fears it's people think i'm bullshitting
but it's the truth no i he's one of you
you've had that since you were a kid
yeah the birds as far as i can remember
so it's the bird would you rather listen
to a whole album of clyden's klein water
or go to a bird sink joy you could
[ __ ] put me in a stadium with john
fogarty
i'd rather listen to that [ __ ] than
being like anywhere near a bird
yeah it seems like this is a more pride
because the the ccr fear is like he said
it's like a superstition
cursed and something bad will happen
which is a fear but this seems like it's
like a
deep primal like the bird's gonna
[ __ ] kill me do you remember the
first time you were struck by a fear of
birds i think it was at i was a little
boy and we went to the farmer's market
and there were pigeons and
i just freaked the [ __ ] out
like that that was what was it about
them that scared you i don't know i
don't know i don't know what this fear
is i don't know if something happened
when i was a baby or
i don't know it just freaks me out have
you asked your parents
yeah they they don't know
yeah todd used to make you sleep in a
cage with a bunch of pigeons that's
right exactly
do you feel that your phobia of beards
is is affecting your quality of life of
beards
[Laughter]
sorry
um no because i just will go to
locations where like
they're really not there or
it's definitely gotten better over the
years since i was younger like i can
just learn to ignore them but if it's
more of like if i'm really like face to
face with it then i start freaking out
what if i gave you one single solitary
bird feather would that freak you out
not so much no it's more of just
multiple
feathers and
i just don't something about it landing
on my head oh yeah i don't know what
that is
how interesting yeah yeah the bird so
specific have you seen the movie birds
yeah that doesn't really bug me
oh you can watch them yeah oh
so it's really just being physically
like near yeah
because that's something we could maybe
work through on this show
dude i uh like i said please do not baby
steps baby said no what's working with
your consent
everything with your consent
i mentioned like maybe we could do like
an exposure therapy with everyone's
fears and it was a hard like no
wouldn't you be interested if we had
like let's say
um
let's just say hypothetically
uh we had a bird tamer come
and it was like tied to his arm so it
couldn't fly he couldn't move couldn't
go anywhere he was just on his arm and
you could stand near him the bird but
you would know the bird could not fly on
your head you could not fly it could not
leave the tamer's arm it wouldn't like
touch my body or anything no no no no of
course not couldn't leave the arm just
being your prayers just being in your
presence
just you know to get to try to start a
feel
uh that that this is not gonna go on
your head i mean
[Music]
i i don't know okay sounds sounds like a
no
what if the bird
like a carrier pigeon has like the
little thing the bird has a rolex
and if you let it land
on you the rolex of yours
that's definitely something to think
about
would you let a bird go on your head for
a rolex oh [ __ ]
the greatest fear a bird on your head
i
i don't know i'd have to think about it
okay that's interesting something
something to look forward to a little
bit
a bird on the head
it's so specific yeah i don't know what
it is
i do have to say i have been keeping an
eye on the chat and i i've seen a decent
amount of people say that they are also
afraid of birds so i think this is
actually more common than maybe i
thought at least because when you told
me i was like birds but i've seen a lot
of people say this isn't the way they
like move like they're all
yeah but they're weird it's the
fluttering that really the flutter the
flapping the fluttering like cam
sometimes has a like can we do a sound
effects of water
can we get that dan on the soundboard
the flutterings like that i think i hate
that one really i hate that no i think
either hates the flooding i hate that
from cockroaches
you can't write off all flutters in the
whole world uh no no when you did that
it made me think of the cockroach
we got to get a bird fluttering sound
for
no
is that going to disturb you if we play
bird fluttering
we won't play it we won't play it
see that just sounds kind of majestic
yeah it's like rainforest sound effects
right
birds in the morning chirping in wings
fluttering videos for cats
like i remember one of the most
horrifying days of my life was
a bird flew into our house one time
and i just i [ __ ] like
like i'm like [ __ ] this i ran outside
and i like for [ __ ] a month straight
i thought this thing was still in there
even though i saw it with my eyes leave
our house right
freaked me out and then when i was
younger we used to get nests up in our
like front doorway you know i couldn't
walk in the [ __ ] house though
i was so scared of it [ __ ] coming on
my head it's so weird the head thing i
don't know
okay
well
we might have some propositions for you
in the near future
all right well thanks for sharing yeah
thanks for lying
huh yeah birds you put them
baby what are you afraid of
my aunt
different answer i was going to say
being robbed because i've been robbed
before in my house but last night i had
a dream of my aunt and it reminds me of
like that deep hidden fear i have for
her
she's like super religious and like
scared the [ __ ] out of me and my cousins
growing up and like we memed it as we've
gotten older but
like looking back i feel like i still
have some of that like fear in my head
like
her voice is always in my head when i do
something wrong like oh yeah i'm going
to hell because of her well yeah she did
a number on all of us you told me a
little bit about her what she did she
used to tell all you guys that you would
go to hell probably i didn't even know i
guess i'm ignorant but i didn't know
that uh hell was a big part of islam but
apparently it is it's like the biggest
part
i didn't think not really but i mean
like we can't do anything we're a good
tool going to hell for anything yeah
judaism is the one that's unique in that
it
uh
there is a jewish hell but it it's not
this it's not really the same as
christian or uh islamic uh hell well i
always hear christians talking about
burning
but i never hear see muslims being like
you're going to hell very soon
i'll never forget i was like
eight years old and i was playing i
think like super smash some of my
cousins and
or whatever it was and i said something
good about my dad i was like yeah my dad
got me this or and they're like oh you
guys are men and my aunt's in the
background she goes oh yeah yeah your
dad's great this is her brother by the
way too bad he's going to hell i'm like
what's up
yeah yeah you're dead you're both your
parents
i'm like why okay dad's sister oh yeah
sister yeah and you're like uh wait my
parents were going to hell
yeah she gave me like ticks when i was a
kid and why does she say they're going
to hell
because they don't pray five times a day
wow strict rules yeah well muslim you're
supposed to pray five times a day but uh
or you go to hell
it depends who you ask damn
you ask me if he's on embarrassment if
you ask my aunt you're definitely going
you're going for a lot of reasons
yeah that's pretty disturbing for a
child to hear yeah does she know how
much you [ __ ] you up you ever confront
her on it uh
her kids kind of confront her we kind of
meme it now like her sons like when they
see her they act like they see red and
they'll like
they'll like act like they're gonna hit
her we're not really they put her like
in a headlock and act like they're going
crazy she'll be laughing while they do
it but it just became this meme within
our family like and who's cousin who's
cousin tim's mom
that's his mom
bingo
i put the pieces together
yeah i was i'll never forget
because i like it for all of them like
my college years i lived with his little
brother um
and one time he was smoking and he was
high and all of a sudden he goes
i'm like what like what's wrong with you
he goes
i just really had a [ __ ] up childhood
like you know it all hit him
when he was like
22 years old
yeah good times wow
very soon you go to hell
can we have her call in oh my god oh no
can i talk to her oh no
i mean i i don't know if she would but
it would be great content
i've always said if i had a camera in
that house growing up like with me my
cousins that would have there have been
no kardashians
no there would be no reality shows that
compared to that because that was just
wild i would love to talk to your aunt
the hell really we'll set it up you know
what we gotta say that
we that we need to convert you then
maybe she'll call in oh yeah say i'm
open oh boy say i'm a jew but i'm
looking for a new religion there used to
be like these jehovah witnesses that
would come over every week and sit with
her
and she tried to
was so entertaining they were very kind
and like well we believe this and then
she'd be like she was like smiling
before they were done
let me tell you what you're wrong and
she's like
yeah
tell her that i would i'm looking for a
new religion and i wanted her to convert
all right
real quick this one time because the
whole meme of being like
being like acting like we would start to
act like we were bad kids just to piss
her off so like when we were like
nine years old 10 years old my cousins
be like oh yeah we're smoking weed and
doing all the [ __ ] we weren't really
doing it
and so they would always make an
entrance when we would come home so we
went to our house once we didn't know
the jehovah witnesses were there sitting
in the living room
and my cousin kicks open the door and
he's like we about to smoke some [ __ ]
weed up in this [ __ ]
oh my god
yeah but she knew they were kidding
right i don't know oh my aunt yeah my
aunt new but i don't know about the
trouble witnesses that's pretty funny
yeah funny gang
who cares about the jehovah's [ __ ] off
go do a missionary somewhere else
witness these nuts
jehovah's witness who's jehovah
why does she need a witness
not sure who the [ __ ]
you know
like that's
who is jehovah
and why should i care
the missionaries are climbing up right
now
isn't jehovah the name of god in
latin
i think it is after the name of god you
know god's witness
yeah like like
what do you say you say yahweh
yahweh yeah so is it the same jehovah oh
it is i don't know so so they're god's
witness
why you got to call it jehovah why you
got to be like an edge lord just say
jesus
who are you to what yes jehovah is the
lionization of hebrew
who are you to witness god
okay
i want to talk to a jehovah's witness
next oh boy and i want to talk to your
aunt
and then i want to see your your aunt
debate a java witness
very good amy thank you for sharing
damn what do you got for us
um
so when we decided we were going to talk
about this i was really thinking about
it because my go-to when people ask me
this is spiders i'm definitely afraid of
spiders i grew up in an area with a lot
and in the kind of bite and i used to
get bites all the time
but i know that that's kind of a boring
answer lots of people are afraid of
spiders and there isn't really much more
to it so i was really thinking about it
and then it hit me
i think the thing that has like kept me
up at night the most
throughout my life
is
like cosmological
disaster scenarios really like gamma ray
bursts and [ __ ] like that there were
basically i i think what it comes down
to
is
the sort of like
cosmic horror feeling of like the
universe being
so
incomprehensibly big and and the planet
being so
infandecimal uh you know insignificant
rather uh in the grand scheme of things
that like
just one day
the planet's just gonna get hit by you
know exploding supernova burst or
something just like that and just fry us
in like seconds and just and we won't
even know it's coming
and
just extinction event essentially or you
know
some
but what about reality rips apart
and i think it's i think it what it
comes down to is just the the
uh
complete
hopelessness of that kind of situation
like there's literally nothing we can do
we won't even see it coming there's no
protection against it there's no like
action plan because like other kind of
disasters even something as scary as
like a nuclear war going off you know
that's been a topic
a lot lately for obvious reasons uh
you know if you're not hit directly by
the blast you know you could have a
fallout shelter there's some [ __ ] that
you could do
um
potentially you could grow human humans
would would survive somebody would
survive right
but then there's these these things that
you zoom out several layers
and
there's these things that um
there was something just recently i
learned about a new one i was like great
another another thing to keep me up at
night called the false false vacuum
decay or something like that never heard
of that there's basically this this
theory this is all way over my head i'm
not a physicist
but i was watching a
video about how
there is a theory that essentially the
the base state of the universe as it is
right now
might not actually be the final state of
it and at any given point spontaneously
it might just move into this different
state which would essentially just
shatter
all matter in the universe and it would
it would come out at the speed of light
so you wouldn't even know it was coming
it would just be like
there would be no way you know because
the speed of light is how can it be
you wouldn't know
how can the state of everything in the
universe change at once it wouldn't be
at once it would propagate at the speed
of light but then we're good
uh well we wouldn't be good
i mean it's not going to re i mean how's
it going to reach us by the time you
know what i mean yeah well i mean our
star's going to blow up
i know and i mean that kind of freaks me
out too but at least that that's
something quantifying the star blowing
up freaks you out but that but here's
the thing it's in like 5 billion exactly
so yeah so that one doesn't freak me out
that much but that's what i'm saying
these are you've got your own death to
worry about these other kind of things
we can't predict it's completely random
and i think it's just it's that it's
that element of randomness it's the fact
that it's completely completely out of
your control that like gives me this
like deep existential fear keep me up at
night kind of thing well it keeps you up
at night
not all the time but if i start thinking
about it yeah
well the gamma ray burst is scary
because
that's like a narrow laser beam from an
exploding
either a supernova or a neutron star
collapsing or something so it's like a
super focused
laser beam that can travel like you know
hundreds of millions of light years
across the galaxy
and uh
it's very narrow so it's like next to
you know odds of it hitting us are
almost zero yeah but it's not zero but
if it does it just flips down earth
destroys our atmosphere yeah half the
planet would burn up yep be vaporized
and then the other half would have a
really bad next couple days yeah exactly
but actually what's scary though is that
some have theorized that one of the
masked extinction events on earth could
have been caused by again it might have
happened before yeah they're not that's
just a theory
it's possible that
that's come around once before and it
basically hit the reset button on life
on the planet and it had to re-evolve
from scratch basically you know you know
you're not alone dan i've had some
existential crisis about
[ __ ] like that
you know
what's worse that are the birds in the
living room earth on your head or gamma
reverse give me a [ __ ] black hole any
day over a [ __ ] bird
spaghettification any day
it doesn't bother me because it's like
what it's whatever whatever bro if we're
going to get zapped by laser then you
know just yeah who cares
i mean zap daddy ultimately i do agree
and that that is you i mean
otherwise that would be a nervous wreck
and not able to do anything because i
would just be thinking about it all the
time but
every once in a while that you know that
comes back into uh my thought process
and i'm like wow i feel you though that
is scary the gamma-ray burst thing is
scary and again i think it really comes
down to the lack of reactivity because
even like an earthquake
a nuclear war
you know it'd be tough
but there's there's
scenarios that you could like think in
your head that like i i'd be the one
that would survive i'd figure it out i'd
be resourceful
i'd improvise yeah i mean obviously if
you're
if you're right under the explosion
you're [ __ ] but like let's say you're
more [ __ ] if you're right outside the
expo or that that's true too
well okay
um
by the way i used to be afraid of
asteroids
but now you guys will be sleeping easy
knowing that we have pretty much now can
say for the first time in history that
there are no asteroids coming to kill us
we have charted every
like extinction level asteroid
in space in our orbit near earth and we
can say with pretty much full certainty
that we are not about to be killed by an
asteroid and that does happen that that
[ __ ] is very rare but it does happen
so like no asteroids in our lifetime or
no like the foreseeable future like the
ones that theoretically
are close enough that it could have been
a problem we've we've tracked most of
them and we think we're pretty good ones
that are big enough to like wipe out
earth right like the one that that
killed the dinosaur right are big enough
to track so we've got we see them all
and we're good they can track its
trajectory over the next like thousands
of years or whatever wow and it's not
happening we're goldie there was one
that i think passed by the earth i think
a few months ago
yeah i don't know if it was an asteroid
or meteorologist it happens a lot space
debris or whatever they always click
baited like we we've nearly almost died
all died yeah i think that happens like
once a month and it like passed like a
million mile like millions of miles
so that's good right i mean that's
comforting yeah that is good yeah the
asteroid thing
that's a that's a solved problem we're
good
uh ela what's your biggest fear
so
um
i well
like for example i don't know
cockroaches obvious
um but like also
uh one of them was giving birth without
uh
but i say it was because now it's not
yep anymore that's interesting
but then like
the real one the most awful one for me
and it makes me like my stomach is
hurting just thinking about it
is just like cancer really like
since my dad's diagnosis the experience
with my dad was like so traumatizing to
me that i just can't like just thinking
about
anyone you know that's the real answer
like i don't even want to say it so and
that's that's the real one that i i have
such a fear of like
when you said the feeling of like
helplessness that's how i felt all the
time when it happened with my dad it's
just like you can't
there's no
way to solve it and you try everything
and it's just sucks like it's the worst
nothing's working yeah yeah that moment
where they are like when you go to the
doctor or something yeah and then they
go
i have some bad news yeah
dude i was convinced you had cancer once
when we were moved here from israel and
you had like oh yeah i have like a lamp
and i was like she has cancer i mean
what else can it be she has a lump i was
just i couldn't sleep i literally
couldn't sleep i was like what am i what
are we going to do i mean
can't this is just [ __ ] this is the
worst thing ever uh but it was just like
some fat and it disappeared yeah
benign yeah it wasn't anything yeah
but she had a lump there she's like and
i felt that i was like
and and then my mom my mom is totally
your mom immediately was like oh yeah
she goes oh yeah
that's something oh boy she's she's my
mom is the freaking worst she goes oh
yeah
you better
uh
oh you know that reminds me speaking of
the cancer thing my my father had cancer
thankfully he was survived it um
but
he had
a big lump on his neck
and
went to the doctor and like did all this
stuff
and removed it and then they like did a
biopsy and everything and they're like
oh it's just a benign fatty thing or
whatever and then
this probably saved his life his doctor
like i don't remember how it went down
but just on a whim or something they
they did a further test and they
realized it was benign
but just coincidentally right next to it
he was he did have cancer developing so
it wasn't even the lump but the lump
almost was like a warning sign
on his body
for
uh so they were able to catch it fairly
early which is i think the only reason
that he survived it was the throat
cancer that he had
just a lump in his mouth
yeah yeah he's a smoker or something he
was when he was younger he
was never a smoker when i was alive but
he was a smoker from like 14 years old
mid-30s i mean probably throw cancer i
guess the 15 years is pretty
smoke for 20 years or something like
that so yeah
oh [ __ ]
god damn it that sucks i mean i'm glad
it's great yeah in his case it was good
[ __ ]
where's the cure man how long we got to
wait for that cure biden said you're
waiting let's go bro what's going on
biden we're on cancer no he did in the
stadium you promised a war on cancer we
got a war on ukraine what the [ __ ]
we got a war on drugs so the police
could both have a war on poverty instead
of warm out drugs into the pizza and
pile out the meat
tupac shakur anybody
changes you called him what did you call
him the other day two packs
originally by bruce hornsby
thank you bruce wants to be in the rain
damn dropping knowledge
okay zach
[Laughter]
are you sure because i always showed up
as bruce hornsby look it up
okay i will
changes bruce hornsby
oh yeah you're right [ __ ] me
i'll still give it the way it
is it to you
things will never change
that's just the way it is
oh yeah
i gotta say both version of those song
is sick
shout outs all right what is yours let's
end this awful segment
yeah i know it's so depressing
i said the music is like i saw people
say the music is giving them anxiety it
gives me two
it's good it's making me anxious let's
put on some really cheery music for
ethan's
hit him with some something upbeat
all right so ethan what's your greatest
fear
dying alone
my biggest fear is that ela and and
and theodore and bruce will be driving
one day and somehow they'll all die and
leave me
by myself that's
scary alone on this world yeah
that's the actual answer yeah i can't
imagine
lost
yeah and a void of nothingness
everything i had
gone in a flash who am i what do i do
what is the meaning of all this
you become a vigilante and my child's my
kid's being hurt in some way
theodore who is now almost three
anything happening to him
would devastate me yeah that'd be really
sad dude yeah
[ __ ] i mean i don't know how i could go
on
[Laughter]
i don't know how the [ __ ] i would go on
because let's face it yeah he has so
much life to live
and he's such a good dude already and so
funny absolutely the just the
the the pain of missing out on his life
would utterly devastate me
incomprehensibly sad it was all [ __ ]
up
[ __ ] horrible
you know
we one of the housewives lost a son to a
babysitter who i for some reason shook
the baby to death
terrible awful
that scares me waiting for uh some
someone to clip this out of context
i didn't say anything to you because i
don't want to scare you but you
during childbirth
and then me a single father raising
these kids
i didn't want to imagine i didn't want
to say this earlier but now that the
background sound is better lena has a
lump in her neck and we're actually
waiting right now to go to the doctor oh
my god oh yeah it sucks baby oh come on
now that's too far we're talking about
theodore
for real yes no seriously that's
hypothetical this is actually a dance to
that
it's probably nothing kill the music all
right it's probably not wait
idiot wait what's wrong with melina no
she's probably fine she's same thing you
were described same thing that we had
she just has a little lump yeah
and like it was nothing spot right here
yeah yeah my mom be like oh oh
oh yeah yeah then you start making
funeral arrangements you know
what what is it called a lipoma
lipoma
sounds about all right it's called a
paloma
[Laughter]
sorry about that amy tell me about it
that sucks uh nothing i mean after hard
lina is it soft or hard
i think mine was hard she said it's hard
either says hers was hard
okay wait so what does your brother say
about it lena who's like this hot shot
doctor she probably hasn't even asked
him
she hasn't asked why
don't wanna
ring the bells before it's
anything
that's family you don't want to worry
you're getting it taken care of i was
having a dance party bro i'm sorry sorry
i can't get back to the music what do
you guys want from ab you were saying
way worse things wait i mean not worse
but like you were saying
would it bring the mood down
nobody's actively trying to kill bru
shake bruce to death okay but
what do you guys want for me i'm just
worried about lena now
well i wasn't done i had more fears okay
let's keep them going yeah bring the
music back up
well i hope lena doesn't have cancer
[Music]
yeah so
theodore developing
a
childhood cancer bruce okay we're gonna
need to go into detail
childhood cancer ela
dying
and agonizing death me
dying
and agonizing death
throw your hands in the air
hey
hey
get it out now okay
let's go
no but like besides that stuff my my
actual like phobia
is of
huge waves
right
you told me about it you kind of made me
also kind of joined the club because i
am terrified of massive waves yeah
talking like tsunamis
okay so
growing up in socal i used to go to the
beach and it's really choppy in l.a and
cold and some days the waves are just
huge and like if you've never been to a
beach like uh with powerful waves
they're they're so powerful and you just
have no control you just get
ragdolled and i used to go to the beach
a lot and i just
you know when the waves are really big
it's just so [ __ ] scary and i think i
used to get peer pressure and going out
there oh
that's not good i and i actually you may
be surprised to lose but i am a good
swimmer i'm a strong swimmer
and uh
the ocean wave so anyway i have
reoccurring dreams
of a massive like hundred foot wave
kidding the coast and just being like
being there looking at it
and uh that's like a reoccurring
nightmare i have so
giant waves definitely scared the [ __ ]
out of me i uh i i i've had dreams like
that uh i've almost i almost died at the
ocean because there were waves so gnarly
that a boogie board was holding me under
and the tide was just horrific that i
couldn't get up and get air it was awful
yeah i've been i've been through similar
situations at the beach but yeah it's
scary i mean
i don't i don't i don't go in the water
when it's when it's not like really mild
i don't think people understand though
if you come to california
because east coast beach is like nice or
for me i came from like
the mediterranean it's not even ocean
yeah but i i never like had any fear
about being in the water or anything
like that
and then when we were in the ocean in
santa cruz it totally got it like it's
scary it's like real [ __ ] yeah it's real
[ __ ] there's animals there too yeah that
too it's like sharks but just the water
like you get tired and it's cold and
like yeah
me and hila we used to put on wetsuits
and there's like a harbor in santa cruz
and we would just swim out as far as we
could
and one day we swam like all the way so
far out
as we were like the pier right or way
further
way further yeah
and we were like amongst boaters and
[ __ ]
and then we tried going swimming back
we're like okay freezing cold we have
full body wetsuits we start swimming
back
and there's a current going against us
and
it just it took us like two hours to
swim in and elo was so exhausted and
like shaking she was so yeah i was
dragging her back it was
scary of the water it's scary and i'm a
drag her getting
good swimmer too yeah but you get tired
and cold
yeah
yeah it was crazy
i almost asked a boater to help take us
out i was like no we can do this that's
embarrassing
rather die
not embarrassing for coast guard to come
pick my dumb ass out of the water i mean
i guess can you imagine but that's what
they're there but we made it
but i put my legs around her and i was
like breast stroking
it was crazy
but we also saw like uh there's a lot of
surfers there and you do see big waves
you know oh those people are insane yeah
they're up there i know they i know
exactly
yeah up in by santa cruz yeah in santa
cruz yeah at the lighthouse yeah
you surf there that's like one of the
craziest surf spots in the country when
i was a teenager wow seriously yeah my
uh my cousin who got me into it uh was
up there
let me show you the surf spot i don't
know if dad
anne's ripping the narner dude i mean
unless there's multiple lighthouses i
know what you're i think i know what
you're talking about i think it's
probably the one kind of by the like
by the boardwalk dude yeah yeah yeah
dude some on a big day the waves are
insane dude
they have surf competitions here and
stuff
it's really interesting because the
boardwalk runs parallel to how the waves
crash right so you can watch everything
from the uh
the beach walk dude those are no time uh
dude they get so big there it's it's
[ __ ] terrifying
not many people will will paddle out on
a day like this yeah uh i don't think it
was ever like
quite this big when i was down there i
was only this big a few times and i was
like
one time my competition yeah there was a
huge surf competition look at that i
mean it's it's it's that that is
terrifying
imagine that crashing on you yeah
you ever see a point break ethan
wait what point break point
awesome how we never talked about point
break zack that's like my favorite movie
it makes so much [ __ ] sense if that's
your favorite movie like
santa cruz beautiful place man yeah i
love santa cruz such a nice boardwalk
there just to ride your bike watch the
waves
by the way the surfers here get super
territorial like
they'll [ __ ] you up yeah i gotta kill
that a few times
really if you're not a really good
surfer that knows all the etiquette oh
man exactly
relatively new and uh well
because you don't want to mess other
people up yeah you can you can get it
for sure you can get her to hurt other
people if you're not really good out
there
but there's like really crazy surfer
culture they get
super aggro
[Music]
damn that thing is
yeah yeah it's great beautiful we're
gonna make a trip again sometime soon
big steamer lane baby
there's a great uh
sublime song where he mentions
steamers lane
his favorite surf spots
there you have it
eh battle out how did you know that you
just google it
love sublime
you can't grow up in southern california
and not listen to sublime it was
everywhere it was inescapable
keemstar is fighting with people on our
subreddit all right it's been too long
this show's over but we'll get into that
next week okay keemstar is beefing with
people on our subreddit
um
actually there was a little bit of news
about keemstar but we were gonna hold
off and see if keemstar deuce what is it
uh he announced
it's very sad so i'm sorry to the
audience out there to have to deliver
this news yeah
mom's basement is coming to an end they
just recorded the last episode
wow that's terrible anyway
yeah we were gonna we were gonna talk
about it but then a b correctly pointed
out is like uh he said he was retiring
too and that's not happening so well i
wouldn't be spotify i was like i don't
want to pay you guys yeah that was 10
people that's exactly what i said yeah
yeah i'm pretty sure that's what
happened and also face banks is like i i
know i am not the i'm the messy person
but i don't think i want to have a show
with the guy who picks up his girlfriend
from chuck e cheese anymore either
you know yeah haze is trying to get
investors they're trying to go legit
it's not it's not a great look i'm
trying to phase up not phase down the
age of girls i'm dating
but what a shame
great content yeah
arguably sorry
are you [ __ ] high bro are you [ __ ]
high bro 3h3 humor
yeah we're there like
never forget when they are talking right
through each other dude you're not even
listening what i'm saying bro are you
[ __ ] high right now
super high level content
how much spotify pay those goons man i'd
love to know how much they paid for that
there got to be there can't be more than
10 000 people listening to that
there's no [ __ ] shot
when they did the video video podcast on
youtube they did very very good yeah i
remember
i remember well he was posting it to his
main channel so it didn't really have
time to fall off in my opinion
yeah because podcasts always do really
good at first on the main channel but
podcasts are hard as [ __ ] to maintain
yeah it's like it's like a transition
for your audience too right once you get
to that 20th episode and you've
exhausted all of the easy access people
and all the obvious topics and stuff
then you find out how many fans you got
right those episodes had big names like
ninja and stuff exactly
you know and that's same with our
podcast too you know
the real [ __ ] starts at like episode 20.
fred what'd you do
try to just walk right through the green
screen
dude that's so sad where did they
announce that
on twitter send me that tweet
[Music]
[Applause]
kim starts losing everything
well at least he has happy punch with
fouseytube that should float him
yeah
that's going places
when you're teaming up with the a force
of nature like ryan kavanaugh
oh yeah ryan cavanaugh who is
lost a billion dollars almost last year
is the force of nature thank you only
eight hundred and eleven million
and a million
811 million dollars that's ridiculous
[ __ ] loser lost
who's giving him money shame on you
just put in the stock market
you'd only have lost five percent
instead of a hundred
i pull up that tweet for christ's sake
you find it what time is our movie
how do we afford it
in the evening
okay it's not for a few hours
so should we get dinner
my mom made food okay food got it
are you pulling up the tweeter okay
chill here
me and banks just recorded the last ep
of mom's basement the end
we are ending mom's basement we
explained it all in the last step this
shit's over this ain't nothing
retirement
damn
tragic
keemstar is fired
he's fired bro
play that music stack i see this
celebrate
hot
go back to the tweet
me and banks just recorded the last
episode of mom's basement
[Music]
take off your hat take off your hat
what's under your hat okay
hey i went to chuck e cheese and saw a
sign up of a dude who was bald it was
keemstar they said don't let this man in
[Laughter]
stupid [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] hey
okay oh he goes i'm just coming to get
the pizza i just like the pizza they
said nope
nice try
you're here for a girlfriend a 10 year
old fan right away
they says here i'm just here to have a
drink ooh red flag
random right on drama dramaalert
oh
oh oh
okay can you believe he's like making
fun of what um
me being fat
well nah i'm used to that until like
like last month bro no i'm used to that
but he's making fun of like the
the girls that you know our friends that
were talking to him and
he's bullying them yeah appearance
i guess we should just get into it
i mean we don't have to i was just like
teamster went to uh chuck e cheese for a
cupcake i think he said his reason was
if anyone knows what reference that is
to
edp
i'm just here for a slice of pizza
just kidding just kidding
should we go there should we talk about
it nah nah
i'd rather talk about tiny tick tock if
we're going to keep going what the [ __ ]
is tiny tick-tock
it's in the duck
let's wrap it up all right let's wrap it
up yeah it's better i mean we've been
going for a while right yes uh two and a
half we're gonna go see batman baby i
love batman it's the only superhero i
consistently care about
batman is the coolest [ __ ]
the movie's rule
and he's sick
do you guys all agree batman's the best
superhero yes thank you
you know what i'm not a big fan of the
dc heroes i'm just what does that mean
who does that you go
dc no
i mean like i don't know i i like batman
um
but i've
i'm over superhero movies i'm just over
superheroes
oh me too
heroes
this one does look good
i just
i can't bring myself to give a [ __ ]
about another superhero wait dan i
thought you had batman as your like
controversial opinion once you didn't
like batman
i just think he's maybe overrated i
don't know shut up
what the [ __ ] i
don't
enough to even have an argument about it
look i don't care about all the marvel
[ __ ] and all the avengers and all that
crap i'm batman
i agree with that ethan i'm not getting
into the marvel stuff because batman's
real you can have like a really good
movie and a really good story because
he's just a guy you don't need magic you
don't need inner
international galactic [ __ ] space
warriors you don't need goddamn amazons
with invisible airplanes and [ __ ] uh
whips made of lightning no it's a man
with a lot of money and a
job to do
it's got to clean up the city
no magic bro
real [ __ ]
definitely my favorite out of the dc
characters
say that
why do you care if it's dc or not well
because it sounds like a good thing
about how like a lot of like dc stories
like the characters don't have flaws
like a lot of them don't have flaws
batman doesn't have a flaw no that's why
i said batman's the most
oh and marvels are beautifully written
like uh what's your favorite beautifully
written marvel character
ant-man
[ __ ] that
ant-man is a cartoon character
i mean his his complexity he's about as
complex as mr magoo
maybe that's giving us like the most
insignificant avenger i could think of i
think the uh the x-men
have like an interesting sort of social
commentary i
you guys are going to disagree with me
but which is x-men is it marvel or dc
it's marvel it's marvel but it's not
part of the mcu not yet x-men but um
yeah i thought the whole end game was
great i thought it was uh it's good all
those movies i thought that was a
beautiful ending to them all
i thought it was a good movie but like
it was fun yeah i thought what they did
was cool but that's that's the thing is
like and then and then here's more like
yeah there's like 20 new videos it's
just like they needed to
do you know when they were a couple
years old
they literally gave hawkeye a [ __ ]
show yeah or a movie
hawkeye is the dumbest most pointless
uninteresting character you guys took it
too far and then you made it even worse
you gave the scarlet joe hanson
character a movie
she literally just has a gun these
people they don't even have special
powers hawkeye shoots a bow and she
shoots a gun what are they doing on the
same team with superman it doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense why are they fighting
thanos they're dumb pointless why are
they there
that's a good point i don't know
ethan i'm the guy with the bull
i could shoot lasers for my eyes i'm the
guy with the ball
sorry zach go ahead when you think of
batman who is your batman
oh well christian bale yeah yeah
best batman but i'm hoping that i like
the new one a lot you know what's
surprisingly good was logan
that was deep for uh oh logan was so
good that was a really good movie yeah
that was [ __ ] that was the one about
wolverine oh i love them that one was
like insane i love that one yeah because
it's like i love this i like when it's
like
a real story with real characters and
batman usually is that
where it's not like i have the infinity
stone
don't take it out of my head
oh
well i take the infinity stone out i'm
the guy with the bow
i turn into hulk
oh
it's just a bunch of dumb scenes like
let's be honest there's no complexity i
don't know there's no complexity to
those characters
i'm tony stark i'm all right so courtney
chat said tell us what powers batman has
that's why he's great no he is doesn't
have they have a point you were just
ranting about how hawkeye's stupid
because he doesn't have any powers he's
stupid because he's on the same team as
superman no he's not what the [ __ ] are
you talking about he's not with
he made the justice league hawkeye's a
dumb [ __ ] with a bow i think hot guy and
batman are kind of similar no they're
nothing alive
hawkeye is a dumb little leprechaun
outfit in a bow batman's the greatest
detective that ever lived you know they
both have like
themes about winged creatures bats and
hawks it's really starting to hit me
that they're kind of the same thing
hawkeye doesn't [ __ ] like batman though
batman [ __ ] dude
looks cool come on sorry batman's batman
batman is kind of an insult oh no how do
you figure tony stark
he lives by himself bruce wayne what
intel lives by yourself he's sigma if
anything he's an eligible bachelor bruce
wayne yeah he's just sick he [ __ ] dude
he's a billionaire
has added a loan to all he's just
you know what i think bruce wayne
you're not gonna like this
don't say i think he's on the flight
logs
i don't know he's pretty busy
i don't think bruce wayne has time for
anything that's kind of a good point
like if he was the real
um
well look he's playing it okay his
parents died when he was a kid
by the time he turned to 18 he went on
his crazy like missionary work he lost
his mind and then he went to a monastery
okay when he was 18.
he comes back he's already put on the
mat he's pretending to be the socialite
he's a billionaire he's running the most
big powerful company in the world that's
definitely the type of guy to be on the
time to go to epstein's island he's been
jerking it since rachel died
right
wow
the chat's asking me to defend uh tony
tony stark tony stark's fine he's the
most interesting character of them all i
guess he is he's more the batman isn't
he that makes more sense yeah
yeah exactly
exactly thank you yeah iron man doesn't
have any power i was really just saying
that to piss you i know how much you
hate hawkeye
but that's right iron man
and bruce wayne are very similar yeah
i'm gonna say that thank you
cool
glad we got to the bottom of that
yeah hawkeye all right
but uh i see people in the chat or i saw
someone say batman is red pill please
don't say that how would you talk about
a red belt batman's a huge republican
no kidding he would be
he literally owns like a weapon like an
army his parents built that company he
had nothing to do with making yeah
he takes the law into his own hands he
thinks he's above the law just because
he's rich
kind of a dick
well yeah but he's probably one of the
good ones you know he's like he's a
reagan uh republican not like a dropper
like the character arc of like elon musk
you know yeah i don't know man or bezos
sassy
you know well sassy
but he didn't build the car or does zuck
right even worse he's a [ __ ] failsafe
he's definitely a trust fund baby
but it's like he said to his girlfriend
he goes it's not she's she goes it's not
what we are who we are on the inside
it's what we do that counts right
that's what batman is he puts on the
mask it's about action it's about
cleaning up the city it's not power it's
about drive
there's another note batman saves the
city iron man save the universe
we all have our goals xavier
i'm sure there's a save the universe
plotline somewhere in batman there's
like [ __ ] 80 years of stories at this
point doomsday
best batman by the way is the animated
one from when we were kids yeah loved
that show that's when i started loving
that show that's the christian bale the
christian bale um
uh a chris nolan trilogy was insane
though that was like mind-blowing that
whole trilogy i disagree i think george
clooney is the best man
michael keaton obviously the most
realistic
what about the val kilmer batman val
kilmer batman yeah man
so good
oh before we go i wanted to share some
proof of me
i am the fart in the jar oh this was the
title of the episode belle duffin farts
in a jar and sends it to me and jay
station what
but only if you'll fart in a mason jar
and send it to me and then we'll have
zach sniff it on air that's what we just
said fart in a mason jar yep send it to
me my idea i want one and zach's going
to smoke keep going too you talk about
it more you suggest let's go
cut me in
but i'm actually i'm actually afraid
this is above the god tier how much are
you willing to pay yeah that's what i
was just hesitating i was like well oh
[ __ ] i don't want 500 for the god tier
well how okay well you you tell me you
tweet at me if you're watching this
how much it will take to get you to fart
in a mason jar that's the papa blast
yeah the papa bless move there you go
but i want it to be a permanent um
wait you're saying it would be above a
500 tier and amaranth is selling it for
a thousand right this is all lining up
it's all lining up
this is 2019. like i said years ahead of
the game yes man you really are can't
take that away from you
guys all right that's it hope you all
had fun i hope you all have a great
weekend
can i just chat is asking about behind
the scenes there is behind the scenes
i'll be up after the episode peace and
love for members
peace and love thank you to our members
all members
get access to the bts
like and subscribe remember
[Applause]
the harder you press the subscribe
button the better
youtube actually they have a touch
sensitive
algorithm
oh smash it is that one of your ideas is
this a new idea in the making a touch
sensitive
might be
yeah
smash it like smash that like button
smash it like
keemstar smashes at the skee ball
at okay chuck e cheese
he gets really good because he spends a
lot of time there
and there's no better way to impress the
babes than a high level skee-ball
score rack up those tickets
yeah rumor has it
[Laughter]
wait these are all him in the pool with
that
crazy and all of them are side shots too
oh wait there's one where he doesn't
have that yeah where he strategically
placed his goggles where his hat would
be that's my favorite actually oh it's
gargle yeah
it's the only one without a hat he
dropped his hat in the pool he's looking
for him looking forward with the goggles
he's diving
that's awesome
wow love that
you pull that right up huh
all right guys have a great weekend
we'll be back on monday and also you
know we'll come back to doing
pre-recorded up soon where you got where
that members will get their early access
but until then we're still kind of on
baby mode
and thank you for watching
shout out to your family a shout out to
the family
we'll do the real raw ritual with more
and e.t share relax with the ringer see
y'all